EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IS NOW IN
SESSION. HE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING A FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE HAVE WITNESSES WERE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE USE THE RAZOR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME YOU RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO ON
MUTE. POLICE SELECTOR ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. A LOT OF PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH MID MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY AS WELL.
PROHIBITION INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED. ON
OUR COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WILL
ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO
SIX. EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE PUBLIC THAT THEY HAVE THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE TAKEN AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
HEARING ALL THE PANELS. OF
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA PRIOR
TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AND ONCE YOU'VE HEARD ALL THE
WITNESSES WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON THE TOPICS
OF TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC.
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. I'M
GIVING FOR GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARYIN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED. FROM REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. OUR
HEARING TODAY. INVOLVES THE
CLIMATE EMERGENCY. AND WHO WILL
BE BURDENED BY THIS EMERGENCY.
WE TALK ABOUT NATURAL DISASTERS
OCCURRING IN THE CONTEXT OF AN
EVER WARMING INCREASINGLY
VOLATILE CLIMATE. WHICH YOU
NEED TO LOOK NO FURTHER THAN
OUR BACKYARD TO SEE THESE
IMPACTS. THE RISK AND FREQUENCY
OF THESE DISASTERS EVENTS
COMPEL THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CRISIS
FROM EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
LINES. AND DID EXAMINE MORE
CLOSELY WHO WILL BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
POPULATIONS WILL BE IN THE
SPOTLIGHT OF TODAY'S HEARING.
WORKING PEOPLE WOMEN OF COLOR
PEOPLE LIVING IN POVERTY PEOPLE
LIVING WITH PHYSICAL AND
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
DEPENDENT ON MACHINES. SENIORS
AND THE ELDERLY PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
CHALLENGES PEOPLE MET MAY
LIKELY BE LESS. ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE RECEIVED
WARNINGS AND UPDATES NEEDED TO
SAFELY EVACUATE TO PROTECT
THEM. YOU SEE THE FOLKS IN
GERMANY SUFFERING. MANY LIVING
IN OLDER AND DISABLED CARE
DYING FROM EXTREME FLOODING.
SEEM THE SAME IN MY OWN
BACKYARD. GOING THROUGH THE
WILL OF THE FIRE. IS BACK. I
SAW MY OWN FAMILY. GET IMPACTED
AND IT'S TRAUMATIZED ME IN A
WAY THAT- SORT OF LED ME TO
ACTION HERE BUT WATCHING MY
NINETY TWO YEAR OLD GRANDFATHER
STUCK ON A ROAD FOR EIGHT
HOURS- IN A LOG JAM ON THE ON
THE P. C. H. NO ACCESS TO A
RESTROOM ENDED UP IN THE I. C.
U. N. MONTHS FEW MONTHS AFTER
THAT- WE LOST. OUR WEATHER THAT
KIND OF VICTIM IS SEEN AS A
VICTIM OF A CLIMATE DISASTER
NOT- YOU KNOW THE STATISTICS
DON'T DON'T ALWAYS TELL THAT
STORY BUT THIS IS VERY PERSONAL
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE AND I
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS WHO WERE
ABLE TO SHOW UP TODAY AND I'M
SORRY TO THOSE WHO. WERE NOT
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
YOU COULDN'T MAKE IT UP TO THIS
HEARING BUT I ASSURE YOU THAT
THIS WILL NOT BE THE LAST TIME
THIS COMMITTEE PUSHES ON THESE
ISSUES- WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WHERE RISK IS INVOLVED AT RISK
AND TRY TO DEVELOP A STRATEGY
IS A STATE THAT IS PROPORTIONAL
TO THE SCALE THAT RISK. BUT I
WOULD POSIT AS A BASIS FOR THIS
HEARING THAT WE'RE NOTMEETING
THAT CHALLENGE DESPITE OUR BEST
EFFORTS AT THIS POINT. BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC HIT LAST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR TOLD
US CALIFORNIA'S NOT ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO PROTECT ITS MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS. AND LAST
MONTH THE GENDER EQUITY POLICY
CENTER. WHO WERE WERE REALLY
THRILLED IS JOINING US HERE
TODAY PRONOUNCED. TOO RECENTLY
PROPOSED CRIME RESILIENCY
BONDS. IS FAILING THE CLIMATE
JUSTICE TEST FOR THE LACK OF
SCALE. AND A LACK OF ATTENTION
TO VULNERABLE COMMITTEES
COMMUNITIES. I'M AUTHOR OF ONE
OF THOSE PHONE MEASURES. I AM
FORCING MYSELF AND OTHERS TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK. AT WHERE THE
FUNDING FUNDING WILL GO
ESPECIALLY AS WE NEGOTIATE OUR
WAY THROUGH THE END OF THE
SESSION AND LOOK FORWARD. TO
THE FUTURE. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT- TOOK KNOWLEDGE OUR OUR
GUESTS HERE TODAY. I KNOW THAT-
WE ALSO HAVE. OUR LEAD WITNESS
BEEN A TRUTH TELLER- AND
FRANKLY- A JARRING JOLT. OF
SOME DOOM BUT NOT ONE BASED ON-
ANY SPECULATION BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND FACING US HERE TODAY.
HIS CONTINUES. TO LOOK AT.
PASSIVE TRAJECTORIES TOWARDS
DISASTER. WHETHER WE'RE
CONTINUING TO BUILD DEEPER INTO
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
FAILING TO ADEQUATELY SECURE
OUR ENERGY SUPPLY AND MANAGE
OUR GREED. OR ABLE TO EXAMINE-
FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO
DECARBONISE IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE MOST VULNERABLE
MEANWHILE FLOOD INSURANCE FIRE
INSURANCE. HOSPITALS COOLING
CENTERS ARE ALL AND
INADEQUATELY STAFFED- AND NOT
PROTECTED THE EXTENT WE NEED TO
THE QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING TO EXAMINE IN FURTHER
DETAIL HERE TODAY OR- HOW ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE. IN THESE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
PROTECTED. THOSE WHO LIVE IN
CARE HOMES THOSE YOU NEED
OXYGEN FOLKS WITH DISABILITIES.
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO GET READY FOR WHAT LIES
AHEAD. AND WHAT CAN GOVERNMENT
DO TO WORK BETTER WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS NGOS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO COORDINATE
THESE EFFORTS TO FUND THESE
EFFORTS AND BETTER ADDRESS
THESE CRISES. I'LL NOW DEFER TO
A VICE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE- SHOULD
YOU HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS AS
WELL AS TO OUR- OUR SEMI ARMOR
AGUILAR CURRY HERE TOO WITH US
HERE TODAY SO WELCOME IS A
MEMBER THANKS FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU FOR SIGNING THANK
SENATOR STERN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN CALLING THIS
HEARING. TO INVESTIGATE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ITS EFFECTS ON
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES. FIRST
OFF CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL.
CONSIDER THE DATA SUBMITTED BY
THE US NATIONAL OCEAN
OCEANOGRAPHIC. ATMOSPHERIC
ADMINISTRATION ON BILLION
DOLLAR WEATHER AND CLIMATE
DISASTERS. SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NO I HAS TALLIED THE
NUMBER OF DISASTERS. THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN A LOSS ESTIMATES OF
A BILLION OR MORE. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THERE WERE THREE SUCH
DISASTERS WHILE IN TWENTY
TWENTY THERE WERE TWENTY TWO.
THAT'S AFFECTING CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING OVER THE
PAST DECADE. ALL WE HAVE TO DO
IS LOOK AT LAST YEAR'S
WILDFIRES. AND THE BURN FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION ACRES OF MORE
THAN 4% OF THE STATE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION ACRES OF LAND.
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO EXPERIENCING
FLOODING DEBRIS SLIDES C. RISE
RECORDS. SETTING HE RAVES AND
ARE NOW IN THE GRIPS OF A
SEVERE DROUGHT. WELL THE STATE.
OUR COUNTIES AND CITIES ARE
BETTER PREPARED NOW THAN EVER.
WE'VE NEVER BEEN BEFORE
RESPONDING TO THESE TYPES OF
EMERGENCIES. CLIMATE CHANGE IS
MOVING THE BAR AND WE NEED TO
JUST OW WE ARE PREPARING AND
RESPONDING TO THESE DISASTERS
WHEN THEY STRIKE. WE ALSO NEED
TO ENSURE THESE EFFORTS ARE
UNIFORM THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THAT ARE DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT LEFT BEHIND.
THE US AGREE. THAT CHANGE IS
REAL AND IT'S EFFECTS ARE NOT
GOING AWAY SOON WHAT WE NEED TO
BE HERE TODAY IS HOW TO PLAN
AND ADAPT FOR THE FUTURE HOW DO
WE CREATE A BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOCUS ON
PREPARING AND PROTECTING PEOPLE
AND OUR ECONOMY IN THE FACE OF
DISASTER. FOR CRIME EMERGENCIES
WE WANT TO KNOW THE LESSONS
LEARNED. AND WHAT ARE THE
POSITIVE STEPS CALIFORNIA MUST
MAKE TO ADDRESS OUR DISASTER
VULNERABILITIES. PLEASE GIVE A
SPECIFIC ADVICE ON WHAT WE NEED
TO DO NOW AND IN THE FUTURE. WE
ALSO NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT NOT
ALL COMPANIES ARE EQUAL OR
ADEQUATELY PREPARED TO RESPOND
DISASTER AGAIN THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN FOR CALLING THIS
IMPORTANT. INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR OF SOME REGULAR KERR
YOUR MAKING OPENING REMARKS
JUST CLICK LIKE I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER AND THE NUMBER ONE
THING WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT AS
PEOPLE. AND SO MANY TIMES WE
THINK ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE THE
LANDSCAPE BUT THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE. THANK
YOU. JUST SIMPLY AND APTLY PUT-
THAT'LL BE THE CORE FOCS OF
THIS HEARING TODAY AND- WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO- WE WANT TO WELCOME
OUR FIRST. PANELIST DAVID
WALLACE WELLS. HI DAVE IS AN
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
JOURNALIST. AND AUTHOR OF A
BOOK THAT WOKE ME UP. THE
UNINHABITABLE EARTH HE'S ALSO
AN EDITOR AND A FREQUENT WRITER
ON CLIMATE CHANGE IN NEW YORK
MAGAZINE AND- OTHER
PUBLICATIONS. SO WELCOME MISTER
WALLACE WELLS IN. AT YOUR- AT
YOUR CONVENIENCE- PLEASE BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SOUNDER- THANK YOU. ALSO
TO THE VICE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON-
TODAY SPEAKING ABOUT THE RISKS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE ESPECIALLY TO
THE DISADVANTAGED. IN TWENTY
TWENTY WHAT WAS ONCE CALLED THE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS KILLED
ACCORDING TO THE CDC THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS. THAT SAME NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. DIE IN THE EVEN AN
UNEXCEPTIONAL HERE NEW RESEARCH
SHOWS FROM THE AIR POLLUTION
PRODUCED BY THE BURNING OF
FOSSIL FUELS. WE DECARBONISE
THOSE LIVES COULD BE SAVED. IN
THE U. S. AS A COUNTRY WE HAVE
A QUALIFIES AS ENVIABLE AIR
QUALITY ACCORDING TO THE IDC.
THE CLEAN AIR ACT IS STILL
SAVING THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND AMERICAN LIVES EVERY
YEAR. DELIVERING ANNUAL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF MORE THAN
THREE TRILLION DOLLARS THIRTY
TWO TIMES THE COST OF ACTING
AND- IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
MOST MEMORABLE IMAGES OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN AS
ORANGE LANDSCAPES AND DARKNESS
AT NOON. MANY OF THOSE AIR
POLLUTION GAINS COULD BE UNDONE
BY THE SMOKE FROM WILDFIRES. IN
TWENTY TWENTY SMOKE FROM THOSE
FIRES ACCOUNTED FOR MORE THAN
HALF OF ALL AIR POLLUTION IN
THE WESTERN U. S. UNIT MORE
PARTICULATE MATTER FROM THE
BURNING SOUTH OF FOREST
INFILTRATED THE LAWNS OF
AMERICANS LIVING IN THOSE
STATES. THAT FROM ALL OTHER
INDUSTRIAL. AND HUMAN ACTIVITY
COMBINED. IN SEPTEMBER OF THAT.
TWENTY FOUR OF THE TWENTY FIVE
MOST POLLUTED CITIES IN THE
WORLD. WE'RE IN CALIFORNIA AND
OREGON. TO A CERTAIN DEGREE
WILDFIRE SMOKE IS THE MOST
DEMOCRATIC THREATS TO CAN'T BE
CONTAINED OR CORRALLED OR
COMPARTMENTALIZED I'M SPEAKING
TO YOU NOW FROM NEW YORK WHAT'S
THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS THE AIR
QUALITY INDEX HAS BEEN WELL
OVER A HUNDRED DANGEROUS NOT
JUST A DOZEN UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS THAT EVEN HEALTHY
PEOPLE. BECAUSE OF FIRES
BURNING TODAY IN YOUR STATE AND
OREGON AND WASHINGTON UP THE
COAST IN CANADA AND DOWN IN THE
BOTTOM. THE ENTIRE CONTINENT IS
BLANKETED IN SMOKE. THE MEANING
OF THAT SMOKE IS GOING CLEAR TO
US BY THE DAY WHICH MAY BE ONE
REASON. IN ADDITION TO THE
DRAMATICALLY WORSENING FIRE
SEASONS. SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
SEEM WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
FUTURES IN THE STATE. IF YOU
LIVE IN CENTRAL LA OR DOWNTOWN
SAN FRANCISCO YOU DON'T REALLY
NEED TO WORRY ABOUT YOUR HOUSE
BURNING DOWN. YOU DO NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT THE SMOKE AND THAT
SMOKE IS TERRIBLE. THERE'S
ALMOST NO ASPECT OF MODERN LIFE
WHICH PARTICULAR POLLUTION
DOESN'T DAMAGE AND HERE IS JUST
A PARTIAL LIST OF THOSE IMPACTS
THERE'S- GDP WITH A 10%
INCREASE IN POLLUTION REDUCING
OUTPUT BY ALMOST A FULL
PERCENTAGE POINT IN A GIVEN
YEAR. THERE'S COGNITIVE
PERFORMANCE THAN IN LOS ANGELES
WHEN SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR AIR
PURIFIERS WERE INSTALLED IN
SCHOOLS IN RESPONSE TO A LOCAL
CATHOLIC. STUDENT PERFORMANCE
IMPROVED AS MUCH AS IT WOULD IF
THE CLASS SIZES WERE REDUCED BY
A THIRD. PARTY SEES MORE COME
INCLUDED THERE I JUST CAN'T
SERVE THE COUNTLESS VARIETIES
ACUTE AND CHRONIC RESPIRATORY
DISEASES LIKE ASTHMA AND
STROKES. VOLATILITY TO CODE
GROWS THE INCIDENCE OF
ALZHEIMER'S CAN TRIPLE DEMENTIA
RATES. GROW TOO AS TO THOSE OF
PARKINSON'S. I SAID EARLIER. IN
FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE ARE
RELATIVELY SPEAKING NON
DISCRIMINATORY. THAT'S OF
COURSE AN OVERSIMPLIFICATION
SINCE THE WEALTHY AND WELL
CONNECTED CAN AFFORD TO GET
AWAY. DOWN FOR THEIR HOMES OR
THEIR PURE FIRES TO LIVE
FARTHER FROM THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE FOR THE FIRES
THEMSELVES ARE LIKELY TO BE.
BUT IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION OF CIVIC
CLIMATE CHANGE AS A WHOLE. IS
POWERFULLY DISCRIMINATORY IN
FACTTHIS IS TRUE AT EVERY
LEVEL OF ANALYSIS. THE POOR
COUNTRIES OF THE WORLD ARE
THOSE WILL FACE THE MOST
INTENSE IMPACTS. WITHIN NATIONS
IT'S THE POOR REGIONS WITHIN
STATES AND CITIES THIS THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES.
WITH THE LEAST RESOURCES FROM
THE FURTHEST FROM POLITICAL
POWER. WERE SUBJECTED. TO THE
GROSSEST CLIMATE INJUSTICE. THE
WILDFIRE FACED BY LATINOS IN
THE UNITED STATES IS MORE THAN
TWICE THE SIZE THE POPULATION
AS A WHOLE WITH MORE THAN ONE
THIRD LIVING AREAS DEFINED AS
EXTREME WILDFIRE RISKS. IN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN 60% OF ALL
NEW RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY HAS BEEN
IN WILDFIRE PRONE AREAS WHICH-
TAKEN WITH THE EARLIER
STATISTICS SUGGEST THAT THE
STATE NEEDS A MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE HOUSING POLICY. AND
THEN IT MUST ALSO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE. SEA LEVEL RISE AND
COASTAL EROSION IS LESS TALKED
ABOUT THREAT IN THE STATE BUT
THOSE RISKS ARE PROFOUND. WE'RE
ALREADY BEGINNING TO SEE IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT IT MEANS. IN
THE CASE OF MANAGED RETREAT
LIKE THAT UNDERTAKEN IN
PACIFICA. BY TWENTY FIFTY WHAT
USED TO BE A HUNDRED YEAR FLOOD
WILL BE HITTING SAN DIEGO EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. THE IMPACT OF
INTENSIFYING HEATWAVES WILL BE
FELT MOST INTENSELY BY THE
STATES DISENFRANCHISED
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. BY TWENTY
FIFTY AS MANY AS TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WILL LIKELY DIED
HE DISSECTS EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
ALREADY COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FROM EARLY MARCH
A DENTIST AND HAD HAD TO GO
WITHOUT SAFETY DRINKING WATER
DURING OUR I'M GOING TO START
DROUGHT. THIS IS WHY KAMEL
HARRISON SAID RIGHTLY THAT THE
STATE WATER CRISIS IT'S A
MATTER OF RACIAL INJUSTICE IT
IS THIS YEAR THEY'RE ALREADY
BEEN TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
CASES OF WATER SHORTAGE IN THE
STATE. BY YEAR'S END THAT
NUMBER COULD GROW TEN FOLD
WHICH ISN'T EVEN TO MENTION AT
THE FUTURE OF GROWING DROUGHT
AND AGING INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
CLIMATE CHANGE ISN'T JUST
PUNISHMENT. IT'S ALSO
OPPORTUNITY. IF WE MUST ADAPT
LET'S DO IT IN WAYS THAT ALLOW
US TO BUILD A BETTER WORLD NOT
JUST A MORE PROTECTED ONE A
MORE EQUAL WORLD NOT JUST A
LESS ANXIOUS ONE AND MORE JUST
WORLD NOT JUST A MORE INDOOR
AND ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR WELLS WELLS. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM A PANEL OF EXPERTS ON THE
SUBJECT OF CLIMATE DISASTER
RISKS AND INEQUITY. FIRST UP IS
DO WE ORGANIZE WE'RE GONNA STAY
WITH QUESTIONS WITH FIRST
PRESENTER DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM OUR- I GUESS YOU
WELCOME TO. IN IN- MR WELLS
WELLS I GUESS I WOULD I WOULD
JUST I WOULD THANK YOU FOR
TESTIFYING BEFORE US TODAY WE
KNOW YOU JUST TESTIFIED BEFORE
US SENATE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE
IT WAS LAST WEEK- WE'RE HOPING
THAT THE WAKE UP CALL OCCURS-
BACK IN WASHINGTON AS WELL- BUT
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS
CALIFORNIA PROPERLY PREPARED.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS NO- THERE
ISN'T REALLY ANYWHERE IN THE US
AND REALLY KNOW WHERE IN THE
pPREPARED AT THE MOMENT FOR THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE COMING OUR
WAY BUT CALIFORNIA IS YOU KNOW
IF AUSTRALIA IS THE UNUSUAL
CASE IN A GLOBAL CONTEXT FOR
BEING A WEALTHY COUNTRY THAT IS
ALREADY REALLY BUCKLED UNDER BY
CARBON TAX AND EXPECTING MUCH
MORE INTENSE ONES CALIFORNIA IS
SORT OF A SIMILAR- EXAMPLE
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES WHICH
IS TO SAY IT IS A STATE WITH
ENORMOUS RESOURCES. ENORMOUS
POLITICAL CAPACITY WHICH IS-
FACING SOME INCREDIBLY INTENSE-
YOU KNOW ON RUSSIAN CLIMATE
STRESS I FOCUSE ON AIR
POLLUTION THAT IS THE ONE THAT
STRIKES ME IS THE MOST
PRESSING- THE HEALTH TOLLS AND
MENTAL HEALTH GOALS ARE QUITE
DRAMATIC IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
RISKS THAT WE ALREADY KNOW FROM
THE FIRES THEMSELVES AND I
THINK THAT THE STATE AS A
WHOLE. BEGINNING TO WAKE UP TO
THOSE THREATS BUT WE HAVEN'T
YET REALLY STARTED TO THINK
THROUGH HOW WE SHOULD RESPOND
THEM BOTH ON THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT AND ELECTRIC GRADE
SIDE BUT ALSO ON YOU KNOW
EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP OUR AIR-
PROTECT COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO BUY
EXPENSIVE AIR FILTERS AND THAT
SORT OF THING WE CAN'T BE
IMPOSING THOSE KINDS OF. HEALTH
IMPACTS ON THE DISADVANTAGED
AND AS WE HEAD FORWARD INTO. A
WORLD THAT WILL BE MUCH LESS
FORGIVING. AND I GIVE MY ONE
FOLLOW UP FOR HIM TO THE NEXT
PANEL AS JUST BE. IT IN A IN A
BUSINESS IS YOU SCENARIO IF WE
CAN. INVESTING AT THE PACE WE
AREN'T RESILIENCE. AND
APPROACHING THE CHALLENGE THE
WAY WE ARE- BEYOND JUST THE
HEAT SCENARIOS I KNOW YOU
WOULD. PUT OUT A STATISTIC OF.
POTENTIALLY TEN THOUSAND HEAT
RELATED DEATHS. OF AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS HI IN THE NEXTDECADE-
BUT OVERALL- DOES IT WHAT IS
THIS ACTUALLY START TO LOOK
LIKE FOR CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE
IS THIS. MASS MIGRATIONS ARE WE
GONNA HAVE. YOU'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT GLOBAL REFUGEE CRISIS
OCCURRING COULD WE SEE THE SAME
KIND OF SCENARIO IN CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT INTERNAL MIGRATION IS
MUCH MORE COMMON IN RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE THREATS AND- CROSS
BORDER MIGRATIONS BUT WHAT I
WORRY ABOUT MORE THAN THE-
THOSE SOURCES- YEAH. TRUNCHEONS
IS THAT WE SORT OF LEARNED TO
LIVE WITH A WORLD THAT IS
DEFINED BY MUCH MORE SUFFERING-
JUST TO CORRECT YOUR SORRY I
DIDN'T. MEAN TO HIM DOESN'T
HAVE A CULTURAL WORKERS EVERY
YEAR IS JUST TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS BUT THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE ARE YOU KNOW THE LINE
SURE THOSE WILL BE. THOSE WHO
AFTER WORK OUTSIDE AND HE
WITHOUT PROTECTION WHICH IS ONE
REASON WHY I THINK IT'S-
CRITICAL THAT. WE YOU KNOW WE
TRY TO LEGISLATE MORE PROJECT
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WORKERS. I
THINK THAT THE SCARIEST FUTURE.
IS NOT ONE IN WHICH- WE ABANDON
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND STOP
FARMING IT IT'S ONE IN WHICH WE
CONTINUE TO LIVE. IN THAT
COMMUNITY CONTINUE TO FARM AND
COMMUNITIES AND WHICH WE JUST
BECOME OKAY. WITH MANY OF THOSE
WORKERS DYING EVERY SINGLE YEAR
FROM YOUR RELATED DEATHS. I
THINK THE SAME WARRIOR TIES TO
MANY OF THE OTHER. KIND OF
RISKS THAT WE HAVE- WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ADAPT. AND IN
ADOPTING YOU CAN DESIGN A
BETTER AND MORE EQUITABLE
FUTURE BUT THERE'S ALSO THE
RISK THAT WE SIMPLY SIMPLY
NORMALIZED. A GROWING SCALE OF
THREAT. EXCEPT MUCH MORE HUMOR
AND HUMOR HUMAN SUFFERING AND
THE HUMAN DYING. AND MOVE
FORWARD AS THOUGH. OUTCOMES AND
KIND OF FEATURES THAT A DECADE
OR TWO AGO WE WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT WERE UNTHINKABLE. I'M
SIMPLY BECOME YOU KNOW THE
WHOLE PICTURE OF OUR LIVES. WE
CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN AND
THAT'S ONE REASON. WHY WE NEED
TO ACT PREEMPTIVELY. TO MAKE
AND THAT. HE'D BEEN IN THE
EVENT OF TRULY GRUESOME CRIMES.
A IMPACT ON HIM LIFE. IS NOT
NEARLY SO GREAT. WHAT THANK YOU
FOR THE SOBER. AND VERY
TRUTHFUL TESTIMONY HERE TODAY-
THAT NORMALIZATIONOF HUMAN
SUFFERING IN THE DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT IT'S GOING TO HAVE IS
GOING TO BE A CENTRAL FOCUS FOR
THIS THIS HEARING AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY ON THE PLANET I
TELLING THAT TRUTH WELL LET'S
DIG DEEPER INTO THAT ISSUE- IN
OUR NEXT PANEL WITH NANCY
COHEN. WHO'S HERE WITH THE
GENDER EQUITY POLICY INSTITUTE
AND RECENTLY PUT OUT A REPORT
THAT WILL PUT A SOMEBODY'S
NORMALIZATION IS OF HUMAN
SUFFERING AND THE
DISCRIMINATORY EFFECTS AND MUCH
MUCH STARKER RELIEF SO- MISS
COLIN WELCOME TO WELCOME THE
JOINT COMMITTEE AND- YOU CAN
PROCEED AT YOUR- CONVENIENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN- AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR CONVENING
THIS HEARING- WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO JOIN YOU KNOW I'M
GOING TO SHARE MY SCREEN RIGHT
NOW SO WE CAN SHOW YOU SOME OF
OUR REPORTS. AND THE GENDER
EQUITY POLICY INSTITUTE IS A
NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN THINK
TANK BASED IN LOS ANGELES AND-
SENATOR STERN MENTIONED. WE
RECENTLY PURCHASED ARE. WE
RECENTLY. PUT OUT A REPORT
HAILING THE CLIMATE JUSTICE
TEST ON AVAILABLE VALUE WAITING
CALIFORNIA'S PROJECTED. CLIMATE
RESILIENCE FUNDING ANALYSIS
FOUND THAT MILLIONS OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
LEFT BEHIND UNDER THE PLAN THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CURRENTLY
PURSUING- SO LET'S START WITH
THE GENDER IMPACTS OF THAT. I
AM WITH ITS FOCUS ON
TRADITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE ON
AND A LACK OF FUNDING FOR MORE
GENDER BALANCED- SHIELD SUCH
JUST PUBLIC HEALTH. WE FOUND
THAT 92% OF THE JOBS LIKELY TO
BE CREATED HI. THE COMPLIMENT
RESILIENCE BONDS WOULD GET A
DEMAND WHILE ONLY 8% OF THE
JOBS WERE PROJECTED TO GO TO
WOMEN. ON THIS WASN'T THE ONLY
STRIKING GENDER INEQUITY IN-
THE PROPOSED FUNDING. THE TWO
REGIONS THAT GET THE MOST PER
CAPITA FUNDING- THE NORTH COAST
REGIONS IN THE SIERRA NEVADA
REGENTS ARE MAJORITY MAN THE
TWO REGIONS THAT GET THE LEAST
FUNDING ARE MAJORITY WOMEN ON
THESE GENDER DIFFERENCES ARE
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT. IN
TERMS OF GREETING THIS MAP
WHICH WILL FOLLOW ON THAT SIDE-
ON THE NEXT SIDE AS WELL THE
BLACK DOTS ARE POPULATION
DENSITY ET DARK GREEN IT'S THE
MOST FUNDING- PER CAPITA IN
CLIMATE AND- RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS AND YELLOW IS THE
LEAST. SO THIS GETS TO THE
HEART OF OUR ANALYSIS THE
PROJECTION OF THE IN THE BEST
HANDS BY REGIONS AS- AS
REFLECTED IN THE TWO CLIMATE
RESILIENCE FARMS- EIGHTY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED IN SP FORTY
FIVE ARE NOW LISTS THE SPECIFIC
ANALYSIS. THE NUMBERS HERE ARE
CRAZY FIFTEEN HUNDRED- BUT THE
TWO- BARNES HAD SIMILAR RESULTS.
LET ME TALK FOR A MOMENT ABOUT
OUR METHODS BASICALLY OUR DATA
SCIENTISTS CREATED MERGED AND
AGGREGATED INFORMATION FROM
MULTIPLE SOURCES TO PRODUCE
DETAILED DEMOGRAPHIC STATISTICS
FOR EACH OF THE NINE REGIONS
IDENTIFIED IN CALIFORNIA'S FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE ASSESSMENT- AT
THE SAME TIME WE ANALYZED THE
PROJECTS AND FUNDING- IN THE
SEVERAL DOZEN- PROJECTS ARE.
LISTED IN THE TWO BARNS ON AND
WE BROUGHT THESE TWO DATASETS
TOGETHER TO DETERMINE WHAT-
MARIUS WAYS OF LOOKING AT THE
FUNDING- FOR THE REGIONS- AS
YOU CAN SEE THE NORTH COAST
REGION- IS PROJECTED TO RECEIVE
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR DOLLARS. IN FUNDING PER
CAPITA VERSUS THE LOS ANGELES
REGION WHERE 45% OF STATE
LIVES- IT'S PROJECTED TO
RECEIVE ONLY EIGHTY FOUR
DOLLARS PER CAPITA- THAT SH-
MULTIPLE LARGE NORTH BECAUSE
IT'S A MULTIPLE OF THIRTEEN
TIMES WHAT THE LOS ANGELES
REGION- AND JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT THESE MAPS AND THE TABLE
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR WEBSITE AT
THE GET THE- DOT ORG WHERE THE
REPORT IS POSTED. THIS REGIONAL
FUNDING IMBALANCE LEADS TO
MASSIVE RACIAL INEQUALITY IN
THE DISTRIBUTION OF PARKER- AS
WE CAN SEE FROM THIS MAP WHERE
BY PA CALIFORNIANS. ARE
CONCENTRATED IN REGIONS THAT
RECEIVE. THE LEAST FUNDING AND
LESSEN THEIR FAIR WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY. SO THE QUESTION IS
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN. THIS IS A
MAP OF POPULATION DENSITY IN
CALICO YEAH AND IT'S
ESSENTIALLY A MIRROR IMAGE OF
WHERE THE INVESTMENT- ARE GOING.
BASICALLY WITH THE MESSAGE
HEAVILY WEIGHTED TOWARD
WILDFIRE PREVENTION NOT- THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF SMOKE. AND
HEAVILY WEIGHTED TOWARD SEA
LEVEL RISE AND EXTREME HEAT
IMPACTS RELATIVELY NEGLECTED IN
THE BILLS URBAN AREAS AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WERE SHORT
CHANGED. SO THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT THIS IS NOT SET IN STONE
AND THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THE- ON
THE FORMULAS AND ADVANCED
EQUITY HI SO WE HAVE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS- FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE- MOST- OBVIOUSLY AND
SIMPLY IS. DEDICATING MORE
FUNDING FOR EXTREME HEAT WE'LL-
TAKE CARE IT WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE MOST
DEADLY IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE CHANGE- INVESTING
COOLING SOLUTIONS PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKER PROTECTIONS PARTICULARLY
FOR OUTDOOR WORKERS AND
WAREHOUSE WORKERS. WILL SHAPE
LIVES AND ADVANCE EQUITY AT THE
SAME TIME. I HATE ALL OF THE
GREEN JOBS FOR WOMEN AND WE'RE
RECOMMENDING A MULTI TIERED
APPROACH SOME- TEXAS ARE SIMPLE
LIKE DEDICATING MORE MONEY TO
PUBLIC HEALTH WHERE THE
WORKFORCE IS MORE BALANCE WILL
TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THIS. BUT
FOR TRADITIONALLY MALE
DOMINATED OCCUPATIONS IN
CONSTRUCTION AND FIRE FIGHTING-
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO GET
CREATIVE- CALIFORNIA SHOULD
EXPLORE WAYS TO LEVERAGE STATE
INVESTMENTS TO INCENTIVIZE JOB
CREATION FOR WOMEN. ON THE
BUDGETS SURPLUS PRESENTS A
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE
LIVES AND IF FANS EQUITY AND I
WANT TO- ON. I'M GOING TO
STRUCTURE MUCH SCREEN AT THE
MOMENT. I'M I WANT IT AND- ON
THE POINT THAT ALL OF THE YOU
HAVE MADE SO ELOQUENTLY CLIMATE
CHANGE IS HERE ON BUT THIS IS A
UNIQUE MOMENT THE BUDGET
SURPLUS IS IN A SENSE A GIFT TO
THE STATE. AND YOU SENATORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HAVE IT IN
YOUR POWER LITERALLY TO SAVE
LIVES YOU HAVE BEEN IN YOUR
POWER TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
LIVABLE FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS SO IN
CLOSING THING I WOULD
ENCOURAGE. AND IMPLORE YOU TO
SEE IF THIS STORAGE OPPORTUNITY.
TO CREATE A CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PLAN THAT IS MORE BALANCED
EQUITABLE AND FAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS COHEN- WILL COME
BACK TO YOU AT THE END OF THIS
PANEL FOR QUESTIONS FROM ANY OF
THE MEMBERS BUT NEXT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO PROFESSOR ALEX
HALL. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
ATMOSPHERIC AND OCEANIC
SCIENCES HE'S ALSO DIRECTOR OF
THE UCLA CENTER FOR CLIMATE
SCIENCE- DOCTOR HALL IF YOU ARE
WITH US. YOU CAN TAKE IT AWAY.
ALL RIGHT YES I AM HERE- I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME TO
PRESENT TODAY I HAVE BEEN DOING
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
RESEARCH FOR THE BETTER PART OF
A DECADE NOW. AND I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF THE
LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED
THROUGH THE LENS OF MEGA FIRES
IN AS MANY OF YOU KNOW. WE HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCING A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN MEGA FIRES- OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS OR SO- WITH
BIG INCREASES IN AREA BURNED
AND REALLY DRAMATIC
CONSEQUENCES FOR ECOSYSTEMS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH- AND IF YOU LOOK
AT WHERE THESE FIRES HAVE
OCCURRED- THIS IS A MAP SHOWING
DISTRIBUTION OF FIRES IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF DECADES. THEY'VE
BEEN PRIMARILY IN OUR WILD
LANDS AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT- AND
IF YOU COMPARE THIS MAP TO OUR-
MAP OF SOCIAL VULNERABILITY- ON
THE LEFT AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
THERE ARE BIG DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THESE TWO MAPS THE-
MOST SOCIAL VULNERABILITY IS IN
OUR URBAN AREAS AND OUR FIRES
ARE OCCURRING IN OUR WILD
LANDS. SO YOU WOULD THINK THAT
IF YOU SUPPOSE THESE MAPS THAT-
THERE WOULDN'T BE A LOT OF
VULNERABILITY- FROM WILDFIRE
AMONG HER FLORAL POPULATIONS
BUT OF COURSE WE AND IT'S NOT
TRUE AS- MISTER WALLACE WELLS
POINTED OUT- WE HAVE THIS
REALLY DRAMATIC IMPACT OF
WILDFIRE ON AIR QUALITY INSTANT
IMAGE OF SAN FRANCISCO- IN-
LAST SEPTEMBER WHEN WE HAD A
SERIES. OF MEGA FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA. SO- THE QUESTION
THAT ARISES YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE
DO BETTER WITH REGARD TO- UP
PREVENTING MEGA FIRES- AND ONE
OF THE SOLUTIONS IN- ESPECIALLY
IN FORESTED AREAS NOT SO MUCH-
CHAPARRAL REGIONS BUT IN THE
FOREST IS TO DO PRESCRIBED.
BURNING AND THE IDEA BEHIND
PRESCRIBED BURNING IS THAT WE
CAN REDUCE FUEL LOADS WE CAN
RESTORE A FIRE SCENE THAT'S
CLOSER TO WHAT IS NATURAL AND
IN THE FORESTED AREAS- AND WE
CAN THEN PREVENT SUBSEQUENT
MEGA FIRES- DOWN DOWN THE ROAD.
NOW THE DRAWBACK OF PRESCRIBED
FIRES IT IS THAT THEY PRODUCE
LOCAL EMISSIONS AND THEY DO
IMPAIR QUALITY WHERE THEY
OCCUR. BUT THE GOAL IS TO THEN
PREVENT THESE DRAMATIC REGIONAL
EMISSIONS- AND EVEN CONTINENTAL
SCALE EMISSIONS WHEN WE HAVE.
THESE BIG MEGA FIRES SO THIS
RAISES A VERY THORNY POLICY
QUESTION- WHICH IS WHO GETS
SMOKE FROM FIRE- DO WE HAVE LOW
LOW TO MEDIUM INTENSITY FIRES
THAT PRODUCE LOCAL MISSIONS-
LIKE THEY ARE PRESCRIBED FIRE
CASE OR DO WE- HAVE THESE GIANT
EMISSIONS FROM THESE MEGA FIRES
THAT CAN. IMPACT MANY
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING OUR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN URBAN
AREAS. SO TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION RIGOROUSLY- WE NEED
QUANTITATIVE ANALYSIS- AND SO
WE NEED TO BE DEVELOPING
POLICIES THAT ARE AROUND SAFE
PRESCRIBING- BURNS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE SO WE
NEED TO QUANTIFY THE BENEFITS
OF STRATEGIES LIKE PRESCRIBED
BURNS ON FIRE RISK. AND AIR
QUALITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING OF
COURSE ON THE BENEFITS TO
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES- BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
PRESCRIBED BURNS OCCUR- AND
THIS IS I THINK A VERY DELICATE
BALANCING ACT AND WE REALLY
NEED THE BEST SCIENCE TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THESE
QUESTIONS. AND FINALLY WE HAVE
TO DEVELOP THIS UNDERSTANDING
IN THE CONTEXT OF A CHANGING
CLIMATE WHERE UNFORTUNATELY
MEGA FIRES BECOME LARGER AS
TEMPERATURES INCREASE. SO HOW
DO WE DEVELOP THIS QUANTITATIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BENEFITS
OF STRATEGIES LIKE PRESCRIBED
BURNING. WHAT WE NEED EXTRA
CHEESE AND A DEEP COLLABORATION
FROM A NUMBER OF AREAS AND I'VE
LISTED THESE HERE- YOU'LL NOTE
THAT THESE ARE REALLY DESPERATE
AREAS THESE ARE EXPERTS THAT I
CAN TELL YOU ARE NOT ACCUSTOMED
TO WORKING. WITH ONE ANOTHER-
AND SO WE HAVE TO FOSTER THIS
TYPE OF- DEEP ENGAGEMENT ACROSS
FROM WIDE VARIETY OF
DISCIPLINES- AND THAT'S WHY I
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH A NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES- TO- TRY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES SO I'M
I'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THAT IN
JUST A MOMENT. SO SPOKEN TO YOU
ABOUT A FEW SUBTLE NEEDS
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
WILDFIRE AND EQUITY- I'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR CLEAN
AIR FOR HEALTHY POPULATIONS AND
THE NEED TO. BRING EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK. AND MANAGE AIR
QUALITY. BUT IF WE ZOOM OUT AND
THINK MORE BROADLY ABOUT
WILDFIRE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT ARE RELATED TO
WILDFIRE WE HAVE MANY SOCIETAL
NEEDS IN ADDITION TO THE ONES
ASSOCIATED WITH AIR QUALITY AND
I'LL JUST LET YOU ABSORB THESE
ADS- I ALLOW THEM TO APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN HERE. AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE ISSUES
INVOLVES A VERY WIDE VARIETY OF
DISCIPLINES AND COLLABORATION-
BETWEEN THE RESEARCHER
COMMUNITY AND THE STAKEHOLDER
AND GOVERNMENT COMMUNITIES. SO
WE NEED SUSTAINED AND DEEP
COLLABORATION TO REALLY ADDRESS
HOLISTICALLY. THE WILDFIRE
ISSUE. IN THE PAST YEAR SO I'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH-
COLLEAGUES AROUND THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY AN IDEA FOR A
CLIMATE AND WILDFIRE INSTITUTE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR THIS TYPE
OF CROSS DISCIPLINARY AND CROSS
SECTORAL ENGAGEMENT- AND I'M
HAPPY TO TALK MORE ABOUT THAT
IN THE QUEUE AND I IF IT COMES
UP- BUT- I WOULDN'T WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS MESSAGE-
WHICH IS THAT WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION RELATED TO. WILDFIRE
OR THE OTHER VERY PRESSING
ISSUE OF WATER RESOURCES OR
SINGLE ARISE- OR- EXTREME HEAT
AND MANY OTHER ISSUES. ALL
THESE INVOLVING INVOLVE
PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND THEY ALL
REQUIRE. DEEP AND SUSTAINED
CROSS DISCIPLINARY AND CROSS
SECTOR ENGAGEMENT AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT UNFORTUNATELY WE
JUST ARE NOT DOING RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF ONE OFF PROJECTS-
THAT JUST DON'T. JUST DON'T-
ADDRESS THESE ISUES IN A VERY
DEEP WAY TO HELP THE EXAMPLE
OF. ON AIR QUALITY AND WILDFIRE
ILLUSTRATES THIS. POINT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DOCTOR
ON ON I'M SURE WE'LL BE COMING
BACK TO YOU WITH QUESTIONS- BUT
BEFORE WE DO LET'S LET'S.
INTRODUCE OUR FINAL PANELIST
FOR THIS FIRST PANEL OF EXPERTS.
SIR MICHAEL WHERE- THE STANFORD
WOODS INSTITUTE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT WHO IS- THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CLIMATE AND
ENERGY POLICY PROGRAM. AND A
FREQUENT CONTRIBUTOR TO POLICY
MAKING EFFORTS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENCE HERE TODAY MR WHERE-
PLEASE PROCEED. THANKS FOR
HAVING ME FOR THE HEARING I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION- FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND FROM YOU SENATOR STROM- I
JUST ALSO NOTE- THAT MY
COMMENTS TODAY- ARE MY OWN AND
DON'T REFLECT MY EMPLOYER FOR.
THE CALIFORNIA- CATASTROPHE
RESPONSE COUNCIL- ON WHICH I
SERVE ON. SO I WOULD JUST
SECONDS- OR THIRD MAYBE OR
FORCE I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S FOR
LOST COUNT AT THAT POINT IT'S
BEEN MADE REPEATEDLY THAT-
CLIMATE CHANGE COSTS AND
IMPACTS OR HERE. NOW AND- THE-
THEY ARE PRESENT IN OUR MODERN
SOCIETY AND CALIFORNIA. AND THE
COSTS AND THE IMPACTS ARE
GROWING AND LIKELY TO GROW
THREE TIME AS WE AS AS AS THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INCREASED BECAUSE- OF OUR-
FAILURE OR INABILITY TO. CEASE
EMITTING GREENHOUSE GASES INTO
OUR ATMOSPHERE- OF COURSE AS
WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH-
FINANCIAL CRISES THROUGH THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC- THE
TOTAL COST ISN'T ALWAYS WHAT
MATTERS AS MUCH AS HOW IT IS
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS SOCIETY AND
I THINK WHAT WE'RE OBSERVING IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE PROBLEM F
WILDFIRE. IS THAT THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE ARE EXTREMELY
UNEQUALLY DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY MILLION
CITIZENS AND- AND THEN WE CAN
DO MORE TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND TO HELP THEM
LIVE AND THRIVE IN THE STATES
AS WE CONTINUE TO FACE THIS
GROWING CHALLENGE FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE. I JUST WANNA GIVE THREE
EXAMPLES OF HOW CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS ARE UNEQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED TO FRAME- SOME
SUGGESTIONS THAT WILL FOLLOW
ONE IS NEXT- THE EXPERIENCE OF
RENTERS AFTER A CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES- WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF REALLY REALLY TRACK
TRAUMATIC AND I AND
CATASTROPHIC FIRES IN THE STATE
OF THE SOUTH AND THE NORTH-
OVER THE LAST. FOUR YEARS-
SHOULD BE CLEAN WHAT OCCURS AND
WE HEARD ABOUT THE SIDEWALL
TECHNICIAN IN SPADES FROM FIRE
VICTIMS WHO CAME AND TOOK TIME
TO TESTIFY AND EXPLAIN TO US
HOW THEY HAD EXPERIENCED
WILDFIRE TYPICALLY WHAT OCCURS
AFTER A MAJOR WILDFIRE IS THAT
HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE RECEIVE THE BENEFIT
OF A GUARANTEED- RENTAL
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANY. AND THE
IMPACT OF THAT IN A COMMUNITY
THAT LOOP LOSES A MAJOR CHUNK
OF HOUSING IS TO BID UP THE
COST OF RENTAL HOUSING
TYPICALLY RESULTING IN THE
ADDITION OF MANY LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME RENTERS IN THE
COMMUNITY THIS HAPPENED IN
CINEMA COUNTY AND NAPA COUNTY
AFTER TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT
HAPPENED IN THE CHICO AREA
AFTER THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CAMPFIRE. THAT IN TURN. IT IS.
AN ALREADY PRESSING HOUSING
CRISIS FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
AND IN THE CASE OF CHICO HAS
GENERATED REALLY AN
UNPRECEDENTED. HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IT'S REALLY TRANSFORMED
THE POLITICS OF THE REGION AND-
HAS HAS LED TO JUST REALLY AND
NO ENORMOUS NUMBERS. OF
RESIDENTS THAT ARE UNSHELTERED
AND THAT ARE- TRULY IN IN THE
MOST BRUTAL SENSE CLIMATE
REFUGEES. ANOTHER IMPACTS OF
WILDFIRES THAT IS-
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE BY LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA IS THE ONE IS THE
IMPACT OF OFFER SMOKE WHICH
SPENDS CAST AT SOME LENGTH. I
WON'T GO INTO TOO MUCH MORE
DETAIL EXCEPT TO NOTE THAT.
IT'S TYPICALLY THE CASE THAT
OLDER HOUSING STOCK WHICH IS
THE HOUSING STOCK THAT LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA TEND TO LIVE IT. IS
LESS WELL INSULATED FROM SMOKE
AND SMOKE IMPACTS WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT DURING SMOKE
EVENTS. WEALTHY RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA CAN RETREAT INDOORS
CAN AFFORD THE PURCHASE OF- YOU
KNOW HAVE A GREAT AIR FILTERS
FOR THEIR HOMES AND CAN LIVE IN
RELATIVE SAFETY WHEREAS LOWER
INCOME RESIDENTS TYPICALLY IN
RENTAL HOUSING. THAT HAS THIS
HAS NOT NOT AS TIGHT SEALS ON
DOORS AND WINDOWS. ARE SUBJECT
TO INDOOR AIR QUALITY NEEDS
JUST AS BAD AS THE OUTER ALL
YOU REALLY HAVE NO SAFE PLACE
TO GO. A THIRD IMPACT- THAT I
THINK IS REALLY RELEVANT AND
CONNECTS THE WILDFIRE ISSUE TO
THE HEAT ISSUES THAT WERE WERE
FACING CHALLENGES FROM. IS THE
IMPACT FOR LOW INCOME
ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS OF RATE
INCREASES DUE TO NEEDED
WILDFIRE INVESTMENT. AND WE'RE
SEEING A REALLY RAPID
ACCELERATION IN THE RATE OF
ELECTRICITY RATE INCREASES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
LARGELY DRIVEN BY THE NEED TO
INVEST IN PRE HARDENING AND
GREATER WEALTH FOR SAFETY. BACK
AGAIN DESPITE FAIR AND CARE
RATES WHICH MOST LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CUSTOMERS HAVE
ACCESS TO IS A LEADING TO
ACCELERATION AND COST OF.
ENERGY FOR THESE CUSTOMERS AND
THAT COMPROMISES THEIR ABILITY
ON THE HOTTEST SUMMER DAYS TO
RUN THE AIR CONDITIONER TO KEEP
YOUR HOME COMFORTABLE ASSUMING
THEY HAVE AIR CONDITIONER- AND
SO IT'S CREATING A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT. THAT
THEN ONCE AGAIN IS BORNE BY
THOSE LEAST ABLE LEAST ABLE TO
MANAGE IT OR FOR IT- SO.
RESPONSES TO CLIMATE CHANGE
URGENTLY NEED TO FOCUS ON
REDUCING OVERALL SOCIETAL RISK-
PROFESSOR HALL DISCUSSED THE
NEED TO USE MORE PRESCRIBED
FIRE IN IN OUR FORESTS TO GET
GOOD FIRE BACK ON THE GROUND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO REALLY FOCUS ON
INCREASING THE RESILIENCE OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND I JUST
SUGGEST THREE THREE IDEAS OR
CONCEPTS THAT THAT HAVE BEEN-
SUGGESTED OR TRIED TO DETER
WORTH SIX MORE SERIOUSLY ONE IS
ONE ONE IS A PROPOSAL THAT WAS
CONTAINED IN A WELFARE
COMMISSION REPORTS THAT THE
COMMISSION ISSUED- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO. IT SUGGESTED THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONSIDER SOME
SORT OF AN AUTOMATIC
CATASTROPHIC INSURANCE PAY OUT
FOR THOSE WHO LACK OTHER
COVERAGE AND ART AND ART AND
ART. HARMS LOSE THEIR HOME. AS
A FUNCTION OF THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE. MANY RENTERS LACK
RENTERS COVERAGE MANY LACKS IN
CERTAINLY THEY DON'T HAVE
HOMEOWNERS COVERAGE IF THEY
DON'T OWN A HOME. AND THEY'RE
AND THEY'RE SUBJECT TO REALLY
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS
BECAUSE OF THEIR OVERALL
FINANCIAL VULNERABILITY WHEN
DISASTER STRIKES. ANOTHER BUT I
WOULD COMMENCE TO SORT OF
BROADER APPLICATION IS WHAT THE
CURRENT TRIBE IS DOING IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CAN MANAGE
THE IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE SMOKE
AND A VERY ACTIVE. CULTURAL
BURNING AND PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM. THEY HAVE A LENDING
LIBRARY OF HEALTH CONSULTORES
BUT THE LOAN AMOUNTS TO TRIBAL
ELDERS IN ADVANCE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND WHENEVER THERE IS A
WILDFIRE NEARBY THAT MAY CAUSE
SMOKE IMPACTS. I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO BE THINKING IN
THOSE TERMS ABOUT REDUCING
EXPOSURE WHEN WE CANNOT PREVENT
ADMISSIONS FOR THE BONE LEVEL
IN OUR COMMUNITIES- A SECOND
STEPINAC PAIN IT IS ALSO YOU
KNOW KIND OF. MENTIONED IN
PASSING- EARLIER IN THE HEARING
IS A CONSIDERATION OF SCHOOL
RETROFITS- BOTH TO IMPROVE
INDOOR AIR QUALITY FOR STUDENTS
IN LOWER AIR QUALITY REGION
SUCH AS THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN. COUNTY VALLEY- DURING
PRE COULD WHEN AIR QUALITY IS
ALREADY. OFTEN AGAIN AND NON
ATTAINMENT WITH THE CLEAN AIR
ACT BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT
DURING SMOKE EVENTS. KIDS HAVE
A SAFE PLACE TO SPEND TIME AT
LEAST FOR EIGHT HOURS A DAY
WHEN THEY ARE IN SCHOOL. I'M IN
A COURSE THEY ARE GENERALLY IN
SCHOOL DURING SEPTEMBER OCTOBER
WHEN- THIS SMOKE IS MOST LIKELY
TO BE PARTICULARLY INTENSE. AT
THE LARGEST SCALE WE NEED TO
REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN CLEAN AIR.
IT IS HEALTHY TO BREEZE HANDS
HAVE HOMES THAT ARE MODERN AND
SAFE. SO THEY CAN BE MADE SAFE
FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE. FROM
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS AND FROM
WHATEVER ELSE CLIMATE CHANGE
THROWS AT US OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DECADES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OBVIOUSLY QUESTIONS
AFTER. THANK YOU PROFESSOR-
WILL TURN BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
STRUCTURE. YES THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN I HAD A QUESTION FOR
PROFESSOR HALL ARE YOU STILL
THERE WE TALKED BRIEFLY ABOUT-
PRESCRIBED BURNS IS ONE OF THE
AREAS WE NEED TO DO TO BETTER
MANAGE OUR FORCE OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA SERVER UNIQUE STATE
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE LAND IS
OWNED BY OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND PRIVATELY OWNED AND THEN
THE STATE OWNS- A PORTION OF IT
AS WELL. SO ONE ISSUE IS HOW DO
WE HAVE A BETTER RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE OTHER FOLKS- FEDERALLY
AND PRIVATELY TO- ACCESS THESE
THESE LANDS TO BURN ON THE
CONTROL BURNS FOR ONE FOR TWO.
ALMOST ZERO TAKE PROBABLY
SEVERAL YEARS TO TRY TO CLEAR
OUT AS MUCH. OF THAT- OF OUR
OUR LAND AS POSSIBLE. WOULD YOU
HAPPEN TO KNOW BY CHANCE HOW
MANY ACRES YOU THINK WE SHOULD
LOOK OUT. FOR PRESCRIBED BURNS
A YEAR OF TILE I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY YEARS IT WOULD TAKE TO.
ADEQUATELY CONTROL ON OUR ON
OUR STATE LANDS- ANY QUESTIONS
ON THAT. YEAH I- I THINK THAT
ON THE ISSUE OF COLLABORATION
IS ONE THAT I HIGHLIGHTED- AND
IT APPLIES- BUT YOU KNOW AMONG-
THE LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AS
WELL SO LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL- AND IN OUR- CONSORTIUM
WE HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT TO
FEDERAL SCIENTISTS- SO ONE ONE
WAY TO APPROACH THIS AT THE
FEDERAL AGENCY LEVELS TO
INTERACT WITH THE SCIENTISTS
AND GET THEM- BUT OF COURSE WE
ALSO HAVE TO BUILD BUILD
STRONGER RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
AGENCY OFFICIALS- SO I THINK
THAT THAT SAY. IT'S A MATTER OF
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AND
CREATING THE RESOURCES AND- THE
FORUM TO ENGAGE- WHICH- YOU
KNOW I KNOW WE DO A LOT OF THAT
ALREADY BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
DO MORE- I THINK THE ISSUE OF
SCALE IS A CHALLENGE- IT'S- YOU
KNOW ONE REASON WHY PRESCRIBED
BURNING IS PROBABLY MORE
EFFICIENT THAN JUST MECHANICAL
REMOVAL OF FUELS- IT'S BECAUSE
LITTLE BIT A LITTLE BIT EASIER
TO DO IT SCALE- I DON'T KNOW IF
OFF TOP OF MY HEAD- EXACTLY HOW
LONG IT WOULD TAKE. HOW MANY
ACRES BUT ONE ONE THING THAT
WE- COULD DO BETTER WITH IS-
REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
DISTRIBUTION OF SPECIES AND
FUELS AND- UNDERSTANDING-
STRATEGICALLY WHERE THE
RESOURCES WOULD WOULD BE BEST
APPLIED- TO- GET THE MAXIMUM
REDUCTION IN RISK- AND THAT'S
THE TYPE OF THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE I THINK THE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY CAN HELP. THANK YOU-
REMEMBER THE QUESTIONS I'M I
JUST HAD A I HAD. ONE QUESTION-
I THINK GOING BACK TO MISS
COLLINS TESTIMONY WE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT WILDFIRES BUT I
WANTED TO ZERO IN ON. ON THE
HEALTH IMPACTS THERE AND-
ESPECIALLY ON SMOKE I KNOW I'VE
SEEN A COUPLE STUDIES. AS OF
LATE- TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF WILDFIRE SMOKE ON. THE TERMBIRTHS- ON MATERNAL HEALTH. AND
ALSO- ON ONG HEALTH FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN I HAD READ IN THAT I
THINK IS A STANFORD STUDY THAT-
THAT THERE WILL BE EVEN FROM
ONE WILDFIRE EVENT ALONE-
PERMANENT LUNG DAMAGE DONE IN
THE GENETIC CODE ACTUALLY OF A
CHILD'S LONGS FROM THAT KIND OF
EXPOSURE I'M I WAS HOPING YOU
COULD TOUCH ON- PERHAPS THAT
THAT ISSUE AND- AND- I'VE GOT A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION THERE BUT-
BUT REALLY ZEROING IN ON- ON
WOMEN AND CHILDREN- ANY FURTHER
INSIGHT THERE YOU COULD LEND.
YES I AM- YES THERE'S MULTIPLE
STUDIES THAT SHOW IT IMPACTS ON
WOMEN'S HEALTH WHEN CHILDREN
HELD ON AND THERE IS A RECENT
STUDY ON THAT- MENTAL HEALTH-
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE SMOKE AND
HEAT. I THINK I WOULD. KIND OF-
TAKE A BIGGER- VIEW OF THIS AND
TALK ABOUT THE WAY REALLY THE
GENDER TODAY MISSION LABOR AND
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF NOT
SOCIETIES AND WOMEN ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT OF THE
CARETAKING INSURING THE HEALTH
OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS SO THE
BURDENS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WHETHER IT'S EXTREME HEAT OR
SMOKE IMPACTS FALL NOT ONLY ON
WOMEN INDIVIDUALLY BUT IT FALLS
ON THEM AS CARETAKERS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND I WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO ONE THING I NOTED
AS WE WERE DOING THE RESEARCH
ON THIS- ON THESE SCALES AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THAT IS BAD
I'M SURE THEIR VARIOUS
DEFINITIONS OF A VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES- IN THE VARIOUS
PLANNING DOCUMENTS AND POLICY
DOCUMENTS FOR CALIFORNIA AND-
USES TO DEVELOP POLICY- IN ONLY
ONE OF THOSE- WAS GENDER. CAN
WE CALL THAT SO I WOULD SAY
KIND OF IN A OVER ARCING WAY
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE WAYS
THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE VULNERABLE
BASED ON THEIR GENDER IN THE
WAYS THAT. WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING MORE VULNERABLE
BASED ON THEIR RACE AND THEIR
ETHNICITY AND INCOME LEVELS AND
I THINK- IT'S INCUMBENT ON
CALIFORNIA TO START THINKING
ABOUT THAT INCORPORATING IT
INTO PLANNING DOCUMENTS AND
THERE'S NO THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK DONE AROUND THE WORLD ON
THE SPECIFIC- IMPACT. OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ON RETURN
SPECIFICALLY AND BY GENDER AND
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO UP ITS GAME ON
THE SUBJECT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
INSIDE IT WHAT ONE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION YOU KNOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT- EXTREME HEAT EVENTS
HIDDEN IN THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT- THINK WOODLAND HILLS
HAD THE HOTTEST DAY. IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY LAST YEAR AT
A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DEGREES-
AS OPPOSED TO JUST- COUNTING ON
TURNING UP OUR AIR CONDITIONING
UNITS AND RELYING ON THAT AS A-
AS A TOOL TO SOMEHOW- AIR
CONDITIONER WAY THROUGH CLIMATE
DISASTERS- BUT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. ABILITIES TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME
HEAT ARE YOU ACTUALLY PROPOSING
THAT WE FIND SOLUTIONS THAT'LL
TAKE DOWN THE AMBIENT.
TEMPERATURE IN URBAN AREAS- SO
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT WITH THAT
121 DEGREES DAY IS SUDDENLY SIX
DEGREES COOLER AND HOW HOW
WOULD YOU ACTUALLY DO THAT IS
THERE A WAY TO ACTUALLY REDUCE
THE TEMPERATURE- IN THESE HEAT
ISLANDS. YES ABSOLUTELY THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY WHAT- WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THERE ARE NUMBER
OF COOLING SOLUTIONS COOL
PAVEMENTS COOL ROOFS- THERE. IS
CREATING COOL PLAYGROUNDS ON
SCHOOLS INSTEAD OF MEANS LIKE
BAKING ASPHALT SURFACES THAT
ARE ON PLAYGROUNDS AND FIELDS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE WHO
WORK ON THEIR CELL CALL OUT
KIND OF RESOLVED PARTICULARLY
WHICH IS BEEN DOING A LOT OF
THIS WORK AND POTENTIALS. THIS
IS PERSONAL TO ME TOO MY
DAUGHTER IS AN OUTDOOR WORKER-
NEAR RIVERSIDE- LIVING AND YOU
KNOW A RENTED APARTMENT WHERE
THE AIR CONDITIONING. REGULARLY
FAILS EVERY TIME THE
TEMPERATURE GOES OVER NINETY
DEGREES. I HAVEN'T YOU KNOW AND
SHE AND HER SISTER HAD SENT TO
ME. ARE WE GONNA BE ABLE TO
HAVE CHILDREN. IT'S ARE YOU THE
GOING TO DO LET'S. SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE. THAT OUR
CHILDREN CAN SURVIVE IN THIS
WORLD. I AM SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO ALL YOU CAN
AT THIS MOMENT AND- THE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND EFFECT IS ONE OF
THE MOST DEVASTATING IMPACTS.
OF CLIMATE CHANGE FOR MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND THERE'S
MANY MEASURES THAT WE CAN TAKE
NOW TO MITIGATE AIR AND MAKE
OUR CITIES LIVABLE. THANKS FOR
THAT- ONE ONE LAST QUESTION FOR
DOCTOR HALL- HOW HARD COULD IT
GET I KNOW YOU'VE DONE. I KNOW
YOU'VE DONE SOME ADVANCED
MODELING AND GOTTEN THAT
MODELING- MUCH MORE GRANULAR
BUT OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
FEW YEARS HERE. AND CERTAIN
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA HOW HOT.
COULD GET. MUCH YEAH- WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT- WARMING AND
CHANGES IN EXTREME HEAT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY- AND BY MID CENTURY
WE'RE PROJECTING- YOU KNOW
UNDER A SCENARIO WHERE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE AT THE
SAME RATE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN-
IN OTHER WORDS THE WORLD DOES
NOTHING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE-
WE'RE ANTICIPATING. A WARNING
OF AN ADDITIONAL FOUR OR FIVE
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT BY MID
CENTURY IN ABOUT EIGHT. OR NINE
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT BY THE END
OF THE CENTURY ON AVERAGE AND-
OF COURSE THAT MEANS THAT-
EXTREME HEAT- BECOMES YOU KNOW
THANK. ON AVERAGE MORE EXTREME
BY THAT THAT DEGREE AS WELL SO-
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN- DEGREE
EXTREME EVENT BECOMES A
120 DEGREES STREWN ABOUT THE
MAN THEY JUST BECOME THAT MUCH
MORE EXTREME. BY THAT BY THAT
MEASURE SO- AND ALSO WE HAVE
MANY MANY MORE EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS UNDER THOSE UNDER THE
SCENARIOS WITH THAT AMOUNT OFAVERAGE WARNING SO- JUST IN
TERMS OF EXTREME HEAT YOU KNOW
BY THAT MEASURE ALONE- THE
IMPACTS ARE ARE GOING TO BE.
PRETTY DRAMATIC AND AS WE ALL
KNOW THERE ARE ALREADY BEING
FELT. SO IN THEORY WE COULD
BREAK A HUNDRED THIRTY DEGREES.
IN CERTAIN URBAN AREA I MEAN IF
WE'RE ALREADY AT ONE TWENTY ONE
ONE TWENTY TWO. GOOD I SEE IN
THE HEART OF CANOGA PARK. IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. THE
HEART OF LA HIT A HUNDRED
THIRTY DEGREES. YEAH I THINK IF
YOU COMBINE THAT WITH- WITH-
THE URBAN HEAT ISLAND WHICH HAS
BEEN NOTED- AND MAYBE WITH THAT
WITH THAT ABSENCE OF STRATEGIES
TO- REDUCE URBAN HEAT- LIKE THE
ONES THAT THE DOCTOR CONNED
MENTIONED- I THINK THAT- YOU
COULD SEE TEMPERATURES AT HIGH.
OKAY THAT'S- VERY SCARY- LET'S
BUT LET ME JUST WRAP UP ONE ONE
LAST QUESTION FOR. FRANCE OR
WHERE- YOU TALKED ABOUT- WHAT
THE STATE SHOULD BE DOING
ABOUT- WILDFIRE SMOKE- AND
DISASTER RISK ITSELF YEAH ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF IT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD CAN
TACKLE IS THAT DOES THIS MEAN
NEED MORE THAN JUST THE AIR
QUALITY APPROACH TO THE ISSUE.
WELL I THINK THE. A. R. B. IS
WORKING WITH CAL FIRE AND WITH
CALLOW YES TO TRY TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY AND YOU
SEE THIS IN THE JANUARY REPORT
FROM DATA FOREST MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
ALL WORKING TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND- SOME OF THE ISSUES
SAID. THAT ALEX HALL MENTIONED-
PROFESSOR ALL MENTIONED WITH
RESPECT TO BALANCING PRESCRIBED
FIRE SMOKE AND WILDFIRE SMOKE
AND HOW TO HOW TO THINK THROUGH
THAT TRADE OFTEN COST BENEFIT
TRADEOFF THAT SUPPLIED BY IT- I
DO THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE.
REALLY LOOKING BOTH AT THE
ADMISSIONS SIDE REDUCING
EMISSIONS AS WE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN OF WILDFIRE SMOKE
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT DRIFTS
OVER HIGHLY POPULATED AREAS.
AND ALSO TAKING STEPS TO REDUCE
EXPOSURE- MAKING SURE THAT THE
HONORABLE POPULATIONS PREGNANT
WOMEN. KIDS OLDER PEOPLE.
OUTDOOR WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO
P. P. HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
INDOOR SPACES WHERE THEY CAN
BREEZE AND NOT WORRY THAT THEIR
LIVES ARE BEING EXPOSED TO
HARMFUL LEVELS OF PARTICULATES.
AND THAT'S REALLY NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE HAD TO DO AS FROM AN
AIR REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE AS
MUCH IN CALIFORNIA- GENERALLY
FOCUSED ON CLEANING UP
SMOKESTACKS AND TAILPIPES. AND
WE'RE ENTERING A NEW ERA WHERE
YOU KNOW THE FOREST IS NOT A
SMOKESTACK OR TAIL PIPE YOU CAN
STICK A SCRUBBER ON. AND SO
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO REALLY
RETHINK SOME OF THESE
APPROACHES AND I MY SENSE IS
THAT A RP IS REALLY IS REALLY
DOING THIS AND BEGINNING TO DO
IT. AND WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THE GOOD WORK
IN THE SCIENCE AND THEN ALSO
THE RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO CANNOT AFFORD THE
SOLUTIONS CAN GET THEIR HANDS
ON THEM. AND SO WE PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS WE MOVE INTO
THIS NEW ERA. THANKS FOR THAT-
ONE OF MY BIG TAKEAWAYS I THNK
FROM THIS PANEL IS THAT A LOT
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT YOU'VE
BEEN MENTIONING STOCKPILES OF
PP- AIDS TO RESPIRATORY HEALTH.
A PLACE OF REFUGE IMPROVEMENTS
THERE LOCAL AIR QUALITY- SAME.
RESPIRATORY PROTECTIONS ARE A
LOT OF THE SAME INVESTMENTS
WERE HOPING TO MAKE. TO PREVENT
THE NEXT COVERED PANDEMIC
RELEASED THE IMPACTS THERE- SO-
WE MAY BE ABLE TO. FIGHT TO
CRISES AT ONCE IN THAT REGARD.
I'M WE'RE GONNA WRAP UP THIS
PANEL IS THERE ANY OTHER
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS HERE- ALONE WILL MOVE
ON TO TAKE A- MORE GRANULAR.
AND HUMAN LOOK BEYOND JUST THE
SCIENCE AND THE REPORTS AND
SOME OF THE GAPS IN OUR- OUR
WORK TO REALLY LOOK AT. WHAT
LIFE ON THE GROUND IS LIKE
WITHIN VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND TO START TO IDENTIFY. WHAT
WHAT MAKES UP A VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE- I WANT TO WELCOME FIRST-
AMY RECALL. FROM THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK.
WHO'S ALSO HERE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE. SOI WELCOME
YOU AMY AND THEN WE'LL TURN TO
OUR OTHER TWO PANELISTS. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
STERN. VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'LL BE SPEAKING TO
THE NEED FOR BUILDING COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE
DISASTERS- AND YET JUST THANK
YOU FOR HAVING. SO I'M GRATEFUL
TO BE HERE REPRESENTING THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK WHICH IS A GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
ASIAN IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES IN THE BAY AREA.
MANY OF WHOM ARE MONOLINGUAL AN
ELDERLY AS WELL AS YOUTH
LEADERS THAT WE SO I'LL WORK
WITH. AND WE WORK ON A
MULTITUDE OF CLIMATE JUSTICE
ISSUES- AS MENTIONED ARE ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE-
HERE IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
BROADER SET OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE
FOCUSING ON TODAY WHETHER THAT
BE FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES RURAL
COMMUNITIES. INDIGENOUS FOLKS-
AND BROADLY WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ACROSS THE
STATE. AS CALIFORNIA IS BEING
PUSHED TO EXTREMES WE HEAR
SCIENTISTS SAY THAT THERE ISN'T
A NORMAL ANYMORE. AND THAT WHEN
YOU ADD THESE CRISES TOGETHER
THE IMPACT IS CUMULATIVE. BUT
FROM VIRAL JUSTICE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN PLAYED WITH THE
BURDEN OF OUR POLLUTING
INDUSTRIES FOR GENERATIONS
THERE'S NOTHING NEW ABOUT
CUMULATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS. THIS
IS THE CASE IN RICHMOND WHERE
WE ORGANIZE COMMUNITIES LIVING
ON THE FENCE LINE OF THE
CHEVRON REFINERY. FOR US THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS PERVASIVE
MEANING IT IS FELT DAILY NOT
JUST DURING TIMES OF DISASTER.
THAT MEANS AIRPRINT POLLUTION
CHRONICALLY THAT MEANS OIL
SPILLS GLARING EXPLOSIONS AS
WELL AS THE BROADER IMPACTS AND
HEATLEY'S BLACKOUTS POWER SHUT
OFFS AND WILD FIRE SMOKE ALONG
WITH THE COMPLETE NINETEEN
CONDEMNING. CONDITIONAL MODEL
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HOWEVER
ARE PROVING DEEPLY INADEQUATE.
THEY'RE QUITE NICE WE NEEDED TO
ENTITIES LIKE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS THEY RELY UPON
PROTOCOLS LIKE EVACUATING TO
FARAWAY SITES LIKE FAIRGROUNDS
WE SHARE LYRICS IN ONE TO TWO
LANGUAGES. VIED AN EMPTY SPACE
WITHOUT TAILORED SERVICES THESE
TYPES OF POLICIES ARE
COLLECTIVELY SHUTTING OUT MANY
MANY PEOPLE FROM THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED INCLUDING THE
FOLKS THAT WE ORGANIZE. HOWEVER
THROUGH HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD TO BE
INCREDIBLY RESILIENT WE ARE
ORGANIZING FOR CHANGE AND
INNOVATING LOCAL MODELS FOR
CRISIS RESPONSE. WHEN DISASTERS
STRIKE WE SEE TIME AND TIME
AGAIN COMMUNITIES COME TOGETHER
PROTECTING EACH OTHER AND
REBUILDING TOGETHER. IN SOME
PLACES NEIGHBORS HAVE FOR
MUTUAL AID NETWORKS TO SHARE
THEIR RESOURCES SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING FOOD TO FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITY CENTERS ARE
PROVIDING ELECTRICITY ACCESS.
HOWEVER WITHOUT PROPER
INVESTMENT IN RESOURCES THERE'S
ONLY SO MUCH THAT OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES CAN DO. APRONS
RESILIENCE REPORT DISASTER
REPORT PUBLISHED THIS NEED AND
CALLS FOR TARGETED INVESTMENTS
TO BOLSTER THE SOCIAL FABRIC IN
SOCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THAT MEANS
INVESTING IN THE SERVICES AND
FACILITIES THAT ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE AND NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
QUICK TO RESPOND TO THE
CONVERGING CRISES WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AND SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE MEANS A VARIETY
OF THESE TYPES OF EXAMPLES ARE.
FACILITIES AND PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS AND ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE REALLY SHOWING WHAT.
ONE EXAMPLE OF SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A MODEL FOR
A SOLUTION YOU WANT TO SEE
SCALE. OUR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
HOBBS THE TRANSFORMATION OF
TRUSTED BUILDINGS LIKE
LIBRARIES YOUTH AND SENIOR
CENTERS FOR HEALTH CLINICS INTO
FACILITIES THAT OFFER SPACE TO
GATHER AND ACCESS SERVICES. NOT
ONLY DURING TIMES OF CRISIS BUT
ON A DAILY BASIS. THEY MAKE
POSSIBLE THE SIMULTANEOUS
INVESTMENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS IMPROVED
INSULATION OR WEATHERIZATION
WE'RE BUILDING TECHNOLOGY FOR
COOLING AND HEATING BUT ALSO
CLEAN ENERGY INSTALLATIONS FOR
BACKUP POWER DURING GRID
OUTAGES. AS WELL AS AIR
FILTRATION SYSTEMS TO COMBAT
WILDFIRE SMOKE. ONE EXAMPLE IS
THE RISE YOUTH CENTER WHICH A
PEN IS COLLABORATING WITH THE
BECOMING USED TO LEAD TO
RESILIENCE HUB WHICH ONCE
COMPLETE WILL PROVIDE A SAFE
AND TRUSTED SPACE FOR CLIMATE
RESPONSE AS WELL AS EXPANDED
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND YOUTH
SERVICES. IMPORTANTLY THE
CENTER IS THE GOAL BEYOND WHAT
THEY'RE ONLY DEFINED COOLING
CENTERS CAN PROVIDE BY OFFERING
A SUITE OF INTEGRATED MEASURE.
BEYOND CLIMATE RELIEF BUT ALSO
DISTRIBUTION OF FOOD WATER AND
EMERGENCY SUPPLIES INTERNET
ACCESS AND CHILD CARE ALL
LOCATED WITHIN COMMUNITY
BUILDINGS PEOPLE TRUST AND
ALREADY GATHER. I WANT TO
LISTEN TO ADDITIONAL AND
COMPLEMENTARY APPROACHES. THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES ILLUSTRATED ON THE
LEFT FOCUSES ON BUILDING LONG
TERM CATALYTIC INVESTMENTS FOR
COMMUNITY SCALE TRANSFORMATION.
IN CONTRAST TO THE IMMEDIATE
TERM RELIEF THAT- RESILIENCE
HUBS CAN OFFER TTC EMPOWERS THE
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY
POLLUTION COULD CHOOSE THEIR
OWN NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE PROJECTS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES.
THIS LOOKS LIKE MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE INVEST- INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS LIKE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GREENING RENEWABLE
ENERGY OR TRANSIT ALL DEPLOYED
IN A COORDINATED WAY I CAN
TRANSFORM COMMUNITIES INTO
MODELS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC SUSTAINABILITY. AND
LASTLY GROUPS LIKE A PEN LACK
THE NECESSARY SKILLS STAFFING
AND RESOURCES TO COMPETE FOR
CRIME AT GRANT FUNDING AND SO
TO SECURE FUNDING FOR THINGS-
GRANTS LIKE RESILIENCE HUBS ARE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES WE NEED A LEVEL OF
CAPACITY BUILDING COULD BE AT A
POINT WHERE WE'RE READY TO
APPLY. ON THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE'S PROGRAM ALLOWS
PARTNERS TO COME TOGETHER TO
PLAN AND PREPARE PROJECTS FOR
CLIMATE FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN
TURN OUR COMMUNITY VISIONS INTO
PROJECT READY TOTALS. AND SO
THIS FINAL SLIDE SUMMARIZES THE
SORT OF THREE KEY PROGRAMS I'VE
UPLIFTED THAT CAN BE ENABLED
RIGHT NOW IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET- BISTRO PROGRAMS SOME OF
WHICH ALREADY EXIST AND JUST
NEED THE RESOURCES TO- REALLY
DELIVER PROGRAM BENEFITS. AND
THEY ARE THEY SPECIFICALLY
FOCUS ON OUR STATE'S MOST
DISADVANTAGED AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE SEE THEM
AS COMPLEMENTARY SOLUTIONS THAT
REQUIRE SIMULTANEOUSLY FUNDING.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE DISTINCT
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
OUR PARTNERS. TO ENABLE THIS
VISION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISERABLE- NEXT WE'LL TURN TO
ASTRID WILLIAM WHO'S THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH MANAGER FOR
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS. HI
WELCOME MISS WILLIAMS TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US IN BEING ABLE TO
PRESENT ON THIS MATTER MS
SCORING TO PRINT MY
PRESENTATION TO SHARE WITH YOU
ALL. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
AND OTHER SENATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM REPRESENTING BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS WE ARE AT A
SMALL NONPROFIT. VERY MIGHTY
ADVOCACY IN THERE AROUND THE
HOUSE BLACK WOMEN ISSUES AND SO
I IN THAT ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH MANAGER
OVERSEEING THAT PROGRAM SISTERS
IN CONTROL. JUST BRIEFLY TO LET
YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHO
WE ARE AND WHAT WE DO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THE HEALTH ND
WELL BEING OF BLACK WOMEN AND
GIRLS THROUGH EDUCATION
EMPOWERMENT AND ADVOCACY- BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS- SYSTEM
CONTROL PROGRAM. AS I MENTIONED
THERE'S A LOT OF ADVOCACY IN
THAT COMMUNITY NOT ONLY ARE
LOCALLY IN THERE- SOUTH CENTRAL
AREA. BUT I WOULD EVEN SAY
STATEWIDE WE DO HAVE AN OFFICE
LOCATED IN STOCKTON CALIFORNIA.
CAN YOU CALL STARTS TO START
THE VIDEO. CAN YOU SEE MY
SCREEN. YES WE GOT YOUR- IN.
SEE YOU KNOW TWO THINGS YES I
DON'T KNOW. YES WE'LL CONTINUE
ON AND LET'S SEE. YEAH IT'S
GREAT BUT BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS AS I MENTIONED WHERE-
ADVOCACY AGENCY WE WORK TO
BUILD HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES BY
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES SUCH AS
THE LIMITATION OF NEIGHBORHOOD
OIL DRILLING- REDUCING OUR
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC CHEMICALS
THAT WE CAN FIND IN OUR
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS SUCH AS-
CAN YOU NAME IT FROM SKIN CARE
BEAUTY- HAIR CARE PRODUCTS AS
WELL AS ADVOCATING ON THE
BEHALF OF. CLIMATE CONTROL
ISSUES. SO WHY IS THIS ISSUE IS
SO IMPORTANT- IT'S NOT ONLY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE BUT
ALSO A RACIAL INJUSTICE AND
SOME OF THE RACIAL DISPARITIES-
THAT ARE AFFECTED. RELEVANT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO TOO MANY
DAYS OF COLORS ARE MORE OFTEN
SPACER AT THESE ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AND I THINK THE
PANELISTS BEFORE AS WELL AS-
HOUSE SPEAKERS HAVE TOUCHED ON
THIS- THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT SOON SO WE FACED- ISSUES
SUCH AS WATER AND AIR QUALITY
POLLUTANTS- STORMS EVEN HEAT
WAVES WHICH WAS TOUCHED ON AND
THEN BALANCE NOW AMPLIFIED.
DURING THIS PANDEMIC THAT WE
ARE IN FOR INSTANCE- POWER
PLANTS AND OIL REFINERIES THAT
WILL CRYING YOU KNOW LOCATED IN
URBAN COMMUNITIES SUCH AS YOU
KNOW- THROUGHOUT. YOU KNOW
SOUTH LOS ANGELES WHERE YOU SEE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
AFFECTED BY THE HEALTH IMPACT
AND ALSO THE REPRODUCTIVE AND
NON- HARMS ARE AT THE HEART OF
SETTING-PRODUCE TO
REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEMS. AND THE-
INFERTILITY THEY'D BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE YOU. KNOW HEALTHY
OUTCOMES FOR MATERNAL. COME
LATER AND- AND TO PRODUCE A
FAMILY. AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
THIS WHERE IS IT THERE SITUATED
THERE WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY
LOCATED AND- BLACK URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS EXPOSING
COMMUNITY COLOR. OR IT'LL
QUALITY IN A HIGHER RISK OF
DISEASE AND SOME OF CERTAIN
TYPES OF CANCERS AS WELL SO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY TENDS TO
BE SIGNIFICANTLY WORSEN IMPORT
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO WHEN WE
SAY FOUR NEIGHBORHOODS WERE
LOOKING AFTER INCOME LEVELS OF
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS AND ACCESS.
TO RESOURCES- SO FROM TOXIC
WASTE AND- POLLUTED WATERS TO
LITTER AND OTHER ELEMENTS ALSO
NOT HAVING GREEN SPACE AND SO
BEING ABLE TO HAVE A BUILT
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU CAN FEEL
FREE TO EXERCISE GO OUT AND
WALK HOW PARKS AND HAPPY IN A
LARGE GREEN SPACE WHICH YOU CAN
SEE. IN OTHER COMMUNITIES-
BACKS ARE MORE AFFLUENT IN LOS
ANGELES AND SO AIR POLLUTION IS
A SIGNIFICANT PART OF THIS
UNIQUE HIGH INEQUALITY ACROSS
THE WORLD THIS SPECIFICALLY
WERE LOOKING AT OUR AREA HERE
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES- WORDS
FILLED. WITH THE NOW LARGELY
WITH POLLUTANTS. IN A RECENT
STAY EIGHT SHOWN COUPLE. THAT
AVERAGE BLACK LATINO- READS
ABOUT 40% MORE PARTICULATE
MATTER FROM THAT EXHAUSTED HE
LET'S SEE CARS TRUCKS BUSES.
THERE ARE- COUNTERPARTS IN THE
OTHER YOU KNOW- COMMUNITIES AND
SO WHAT HOUSEHOLDS EARNING LESS
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND A YEAR.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T OWN HEARTS ARE
SUFFERING FROM VEHICLE
POLLUTION LEVELS ABOUT 20%
HIGHER THAN THE STATE AVERAGE.
AND SO WATER SINCE AS I
MENTIONED IT'S AN APARTMENT ALL
ON ISSUE AS WELL AND SO IT'S AN
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM. FORM A
SYSTEMIC RACISM WHEREBY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED
WITH HEALTH HAZARDS YOU NAME IT
SO BREAST CANCER UTERINECANCER
ASTHMA- AND CERTAIN TYPES OF.
AS WE SAY IN LIFESTYLE-
DISEASES LINKED TO WHERE WE
LIVE WORK AND PLAY AND SOME OF
THESE PRACTICES THAT FORCE THEM
TO LIVE IN PROXIMITY TO SOURCES
OF TOXIC WASTE IN LANDFILLS
POWER STATIONS- MAJOR ROSIE
MENTORS AND AIRBORNE
PARTICULATE MATTER IN SOME LA
ACTUALLY KNOWS IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY AS WELL AS SOME OF
THESE OIL REFINERIES. TO THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT OTHER
RESIDENTS AND SELLING SAMPLES
CAN BE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OR
LIKES TRACTION THROUGHOUT
SOUTHWEST SOUTHWEST ANGELUS WE
HAVE A VERY RAPID CAMPAIGN WITH
A LOCAL NONPROFIT CALLED
STANTON SO TO STOP NEIGHBORHOOD
OIL DRILLING. AS A RESULT THESE
COMMUNITIES CAN SUFFER GREATER
RATES OF HEALTH PROBLEMS AS
WE'VE BEEN YOU KNOW STATING SO
HUNTED. BUT LABOR THE POINT OR
LACKS. NO AT ALL BELIEVING I
WOULD I WOULD DO ASK YOU WHAT
BACK WITH. BUT IF YOU COULD
JUST WRAP UP THE NEW TESTING
HERE. SHE CAN DO WE CAN
ADVOCATE- PROVIDE EDUCATION
AWARENESS IN ON WHAT WE'RE
HAVING HERE- ADVOCATING FOR
BETTER POLICIES. SKEWS ME
POLICIES PROTECTIONS- URGING
ELECTED YOU KNOW ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO THANK YOU MISS WILLIAMS AND
WE MAY COME BACK TO YOU WITH
WITH A LITTLE MORE DETAILED
LOOK ON THE GROUND BUT
SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IN ALL YOUR
ORGANIZING EFFORTS THUS FAR-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT- RETURN TO OUR LAST PANEL
IS NOW ON THIS ON THIS PANEL-
THAT'S MISS KRISTEN TOWARDS
POLLING WHO IS THIS IS DEBBIE
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR LA COUNTY- THE JUST PUT OUT
THEIR SUSTAINABILITY PLAN WHICH
TOOK A- PARTICULARLY POINTED
LOOK AT SOMEBODY'S RACIAL AND
OTHER EQUITY CHALLENGES TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS- STORES FALLING
TO A- J. TESTIMONY WITH US. YOU
MIGHT- GIVE IT GIVE A ONE. YEP
YOU GOT IT NOW. ALL RIGHT I CAN
DOUBLE I NEEDED THANK YOU
CHAIR- AND THEN YOU DO THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING THE
COUNTY PARTICIPATE TODAY I'M
KRISTIN TORRES CALLING AND
MESSAGING ABILITY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES HOUSTON BILLY OFFICE I
ALSO SERVE ON THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS I'M AN INSURANCE.
GROUP AS THE CHAIRMAN SHIN OUR
OFFICE IS CHARGED WITH
OVERSEEING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE NATION'S MOST AMBITIOUS
REGIONAL SUSTAINABILITY PLAN WE
CALL OUR COUNTY. ADOPTED BY OUR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IT'S A FINE DAY FOR
YOU D'ANTONI COMPREHENSIVELY
AND INCORPORATED. EQUITY AND
RESILIENCE EVERY CAP. WELL I
CAN'T EVEN CROWNED IN MANY WAYS
OTHER ONE THAT WE ARE MOST
PROUD OF WITH THE PURCHASE.
EQUITY IN THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. WE SPENT A YEAR
LISTENING TO A DIVERSE SET OF
STAKEHOLDERS BEFORE WE EVER
WRITE DOWN A WORD OF AND-
DURING THAT PROCESS. A LOT
ABOUT PEOPLE CENTRIC I'M
ORIGINALLY DESPERATELY
IMPORTANT LA COUNTY WHERE. SOME
COMPS UNITIES AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. HE RESPONDED DIRECTLY
BY ESTABLISHING TARGET ENERGY
HUMAN HEALTH. LIKE REDUCING 45%
OF THE REGION. EACH STRESSED.
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE IN
CONVERTING THIRTY PERCENT. OF
THE REGION'S HEAT TRAPPING.
WELL DRINKER LIKE TWENTY THREE
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THE OTHER
JUST TWO OUT OF OVER FIFTY
TARGETS THAT DEMONSTRATE OUR
WILLINGNESS TO BE BOLD AND
AMBITIOUS. I WILL NOTE THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE A DEDICATED FUNDING
STREAM HELP US FOR THE EIGHTY
EIGHT. LA COUNTY YEAH. THE
COUNTY LEADERSHIP WITH THOSE
TARGETS. DESERVE RESOURCES FROM
THE STATE TO HELP CATALYZE THE
KIND OF CHANGE THAT WE HEARD
FROM THE COMMUNITY THEY WANT.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
CLIMATE RESILIENCE ACTION WE
TAKE ON AFTER THE ADOPTION OF
OUR PLAN WITH THE- THE KIND OF
ON A REALLY. IT WAS ACTUALLY SO
IMPORTANT TO ITS STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WE WRITE IT DOWN TWICE- IN
OUR PLAN. IDENTIFIED THE NEED
TO YOU BOTH. OKAY SO- CREMONA
ABILITY ASSESSMENT MEANING OUT
OF FACTORS SOCIAL FACTORS LIKE
INCOME AGE DISABILITY- AND
HELD. A RACE AND ETHNICITY
INFLUENCE CREDIBILITY. BUT ALSO
PHYSICAL. HOW DOES OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- DOES THAT.
CHANGE WE ALSO LOOK. AT WHAT
WE'RE CALLING CASCADING
IMPACTS. WHAT ARE THE
DOWNSTREAM RESULTS ON COMMUNITY
FROM THE FIRST QUARTER IMPACT.
WE DID THIS- COMPREHENSIVE
CONNIE WHAT ASSESSMENT WITH OUR
OWN COUNTY BUDGET IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT. THE INCORPORATED CITY-
TO COMPLETE THEIR STATE
MANDATED SP THREE SEVENTY NINE
APARTMENTS. TO UPDATE THEIR
SAFETY ELEMENTS WITH. SO WE
CREATED A CANDLE BUT I FOR THE
RE DID YOU BETTER RESILIENCE
PLANNING AND WE HOPE THAT THE
STATE IS THAT A- IN COUNTY FOR
COMING RESILIENCE OKAY I.
DURING THIS PROCESS WE HEARD
WITH ME WE HELP WITH ANY
QUESTIONS WHAT'S WITH THE BIG
POPULATIONS LIKE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TRIBAL AND
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES AND OUR
WORKERS. WERE OFTEN LEFT OUT OF
THE KIND OF CONVERSATIONS EVERY
HEARD STORIES OF HOW PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS FILLED THE GAP.
AND THERE WERE NO GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION OR WINDOWS
INTERVENTIONS DID NOT SERVE
THEIR PARTICULAR COMMUNITY THAT
KIND OF COMMUNITY WITH THEM IS
OUT THERE IT IS A MATTER OF
TAKING THE TIME TO LISTEN.
LEADING COMMUNITY LEAD THE WAY
IN PROVIDING RESOURCES. TO
THOSE KIND OF LEADERS AND
INNOVATORS. WELL WE NEED
CERTAIN. NEW FINANCE RESOURCES.
WE ALSO NEED THE COMMUNITY
CENTER PURCHASE TO MAKE ANY NEW
RESEARCH THAT WAS PART OF THE
POSSIBLY CAN. ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THE VULNERABLE. SIMPLY
HAVING MONEY TO OPEN A COOLING
CENTER REALLY ISN'T ENOUGH.
WHEN PEOPLE DON'T DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE CALLING. YOU'RE A
GOVERNMENT RUN COOLING CENTER
BECAUSE THE MIGRATION STATUS.
OR THEY CAN'T PHYSICALLY GET
THERE BECAUSE THE
TRANSPORTATION. NEED TO MAKE
EXISTING INTERVENTIONS MORE
EFFECTIVE. INTERVENTIONS AT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WATCHING ME.
LIKE IT'S A BIT. ADDRESSING ONE
POINT- WE EVEN MAKE CLEAR IN
THE FORTHCOMING REPORT- IS THAT
KIND OF UNDER THE LADY IS NOT
ACTUALLY ABOUT IN HERE YES SIR.
PEOPLE ARE POPULATION BUT THE
STOMACH LIKE AN EQUITY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ACCESS TOP
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IN YOUR
LIFE I IT. WAS IN POLITICAL
POWER ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS
ETCETERA. WELL OUR FINAL. HER
FORTHCOMING- WE DO HAVE A GOOD
TIME TO THE FINDINGS THIRTEEN
EMERSON DESCRIBED HERE- WHAT
ONE PARTICULARLY INTERESTING
FINDING THAT A HIGHLIGHT IS
THAT DURING CLIMATE EVENTS JUST
LIKE WE WITNESSED DURING OPEN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE ONCE
AGAIN ESSENTIAL. NEED RESOURCES
TO ENSURE THAT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO EASILY DO
THEIR JOB DURING. IN TURN. ALL
COMMUNITY EIGHT GIVEN THESE
FINDINGS AND GIVEN THAT WE ARE
THE COUNTY THE HIGHEST SHARE OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES STATE
WORSENING INEQUALITY TO CLIMATE
CHANGE YES THE GOVERNMENT
WHETHER WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING FOR RESILIENCE HAVE
BACKUP ENERGY AT CRITICAL. DO
YOU OR EVEN YOU LADIES TO HELP.
DEAL WITH THE NEW AND EXISTING
DEVELOPMENT IN WILD PRONE AREAS
ALL OF THE INTERVENTIONS BE IN
COMMUNITY CONVERSELY REPORTER
JUST FINE. IN TO HELP HOLD THE
MARCH A MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE PROPERTY
TO HELP US JACK YOUR- WE'RE
TRYING TO DECIDE. WE URGE YOU
TO. FIND THE KIND OF PEOPLE
CENTRIC- TO CLIMATE DISASTER.
THAT WE OUTLINED HERE TODAY
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING COUNTY IN
HEARING BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- DECKING. THIS
PANDA- ANY. FOLLOW UP FOR. YES
JUST A QUICK QUESTION FOR OUR
THING FOR MUCH THE RESILIENCE
POUNDS OF HAPPENING LA COUNTY.
SO JUST SOMETHING I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
UPDATING THOSE PLANS RIGHT
BECAUSE- SOMETIMES WILL COME UP
WITH THESE GOOD PLANS TO.
ADDRESS THE ISSUES AND THEN WE
LEAVE IT THERE FOR A COUPLE
YEARS AND WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
UNTIL. SOMETHING HAPPENS WE GO
BACK TO FOLLOW UP SOME REALLY
BIG GOT UPDATING THESE PLANS
ARE MAYBE LOOKING AT HIM EVERY
YEAR JUST TO SEE. LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE YEAR IN THE
PAST TO KEEP UPDATING THEM TO
ADDRESS ANY CHALLENGES THAT MAY
COME ABOUT THAT WE PROBABLY
DON'T THINK ABOUT THE
BEGINNING. THAT'S ALL THANK YOU.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT POINT WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO. CONTINUE TO.
ENGAGE COMMUNITIES THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE THINK INVOLVED
IS INVOLVED IN- UPDATING. THE
LIST AND PEOPLE AND REFLECTS
THEIR EXPERIENCE. AND I'LL JUST
MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT- BEFORE.
MOVING FORWARD I KNOW- ALL
THREE PANELISTS TOUCHED ON IT
AND IS A MEMBER ID OR CURRY
NOTED AT THE OUTSET THAT PEOPLE
CENTRIC APPROACH- SEEMS TO BE A
OVERRIDING THEME HERE THAT
LEADING RISK TO PEOPLE DRIVE-
OUR PRIORITIES AND OUR FUNDING-
NOT JUST IN FUNDING BUT ALSO IN
POLICY. FOR THE STATE SEEMS
CRUCIAL- SO THE MORE FEEDBACK
WE CAN GET FROM YOUR
ORGANIZATION'S GOING FORWARD
AND HOW TO HAVE A MORE
EQUITABLE FRAMEWORK AND REALLY
PRIORITISE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FIRST- I THINK
SHOULD BE ABLE TO AT LEAST
START TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
SYSTEMIC. OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
RACISM OR SYSTEMIC INEQUITY
THAT YOU'VE BEEN TOUCHING ON I
WOULD ALSO LIKE THIS THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE DIGGING IN
FURTHER- AFTER THIS HEARING BUT
HI TO BETTER MARY THE HAZARD
MITIGATION WORK WE'RE DOING IN
THE PRE HAZARD MITIGATION WORK
WE'RE DOING- THROUGH FEMA OUR
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
WITH SOME OF THE WORK GOING ON
IN THE SUSTAINABILITY SIDE- AND
HOW TO ACTUALLY MARRY THOSE
EFFORTS SO WE CAN BEST
LEVERAGE. FEDERAL FUNDS BUT
ALSO GET- BOTH THOSE WHO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
OPERATIONALIZED WITH THIS SORT
OF DATA THAT YOU'RE PULLING OUT
OF THESE EFFORTS SO I WILL BE
LOOKING MORE CLOSELY AT THAT- I
HAVE. PLENTY MORE QUESTIONS FOR
THIS PANEL- BUT I DIDN'T WANT
TO KEEP OUR CHIEF PORTER
WAITING SO- WHAT WE'LL WRAP
THIS PANEL UP FOR NOW WE MAY
COME BACK TO ALL WITH
QUESTIONS- AS WE GO FORWARD
BUT- I'M ACTUALLY I HAVE TO. IN
ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES OR SO I
HAVE TO TRADE THE GAVEL OVER TO
MY VICE CHAIR HERE SO I'M
BRIEFLY GOING TO KICK OFF-
CHIEF PORTER INDIFFERENCE TO
YOU START YOUR OWN TESTIMONY
AND THEN AT SOME POINT DURING
AFTER YOUR TESTIMONY TO PASS
THE GAVEL OVER SO HELP YOU- CAN
UNDERSTAND AND- DO RESPECT YOUR
PRESENCE HERE TODAY I KNOW
YOU'RE- VERY. BUSY RIGHT NOW.
I'M TAKING ON I DON'TKNOW HOW
MANY FIRES YOU GOT ON YOUR
HANDS TODAY BUT FOR TAKING THE
TIME WITH THIS COMMITTEE WE
SINCERELY APPRECIATE. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU YEAH
THERE IS A LOT OF FIRE
ACTIVITY. FOR SURE GOING ON
AGAIN THIS YEAR. BUT WE DO
HAVE- PLENTY OF- LIGHTNING
FIRES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
POPPING UP OVER THE NEXT FEW
DAYS SO- NOT TO FLAG EVERYBODY
TO THE CONCERNS THAT WE- LIVED
THROUGH IN AUGUST OF LAST YEAR.
BUT REMEMBER AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR WE WERE RUNNING AT ABOUT A
NORMAL KIND OF A YEAR. AND THAT
THAT JUMPED. FROM AUGUST
THROUGH DECEMBER TWO- ONE OF
THE WORST YEARS THAT WE'VE EVER
SEEN AND THE MOST NUMBER OF
ACRES OF EVER BURNED IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW RECORD
KEEPING. FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES- OVER NINE THOUSAND
BUYERS SO WILDFIRES. AND IHAD
A STAGGERING 10005100% INCREASE
OVER THE- TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- SEASON SO VERY ACTIVE
YOU ALL KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN
REFLECTED BY MANY OF THE
SPEAKERS PREVIOUSLY. AND I JUST
WANTED TO FLAG A COUPLE OF
THOSE ITEMS JUST TO KEEP US-
KIND OF LOOKING AT WHERE WE ARE
WHERE WE ARE WHERE WE'RE GOING.
FURTHER FORWARD- WE- ARE AT A
PLACE WHERE WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BY AND LARGE- AN
EIGHT INSTEAD OF ECOSYSTEMS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT ARE.
FIRED ACTED- THEY HAVE BANNED
MANAGED BY FIRE FOR THOUSANDS
OF YEARS. BEFORE THE LAST
SEVERAL HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION HACKS ACTIVITIES
PRIMARILY THE LAST HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. AND SO THERE IS AN
INDIGENOUS- COMPONENT TO THIS
AND THE KNOWLEDGE OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES THAT NEED TO BE BROUGHT
BACK INTO THE FOLD BROUGHT BACK
INTO THE MANAGEMENT DECISIONS
ON THE ON THE LANDSCAPE AND WE
NEED TO DO THAT IN A VERY-
FORTHRIGHT WAY. AND AND MOVED
ALL PROGRAMS IN THAT DIRECTION.
WHAT IS ALSO CLEAR AND THE
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME HAVE HAVE
INDICATED HEAT DROUGHT.
WILDFIRE ANDALL OF THE ASPECTS
THAT KIND OF. COMPASS BY THAT
AND HOW THOSE ARE AFFECTING.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND
EVEN AS FAR AS AS NEW YORK CITY
AS WE'VE HEARD THIS YEAR AND
AGAIN AGAIN R. AND LAST YEAR-
IT'S HAPPENING MORE FREQUENTLY.
BUT IT'S HAPPENING-
DISPROPORTIONATELY THESE
EFFECTS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND- BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY I KNOW AND I WANTED YOU
TO UNDERSTAND TOO THAT THAT IS
PART OF- CAL FIRE'S PROCESS.
CAL FIRE. DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
MYSELF AS THE STATE FORESTER
FOR- THE STATE. ARE VERY MUCH
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE CHANGE
THIS AND HOW DO WE- DELIVER OUR
PROGRAMS TO BEST SERVE. THE
MOST VULNERABLE MIRACLE-
POPULATIONS OF CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND. BUT ALSO- INSURE THAT
WE'RE DELIVERING A PRODUCT THAT
CAN BE MIMICKED AND K. CARRIED.
OUT FOR YEARS AND YEARS TO COME.
SO OF THOSE THINGS WE'RE DOING-
ARE- WE'VE WE HAVE- VERY DEEP
PROGRAMS INCLUDING OUR FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM- THAT IS
JUST WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
THERE'S GRANT FUNDING RELATED
TO THAT- WE UTILIZE- CALIFORNIA
ENVIRO SCREEN FOR- FOR SOME OF
OUR CRITERIA OF HOW WE DELIVER.
ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THAT ONE FOREST HEALTH- URBAN
AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY YEAH
THAT ONE GETS LESS ATTENTION
BUT IS ALMOST MORE IMPORTANT
THAN A LOT OF THE OTHERS
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO-
HEAT ISLAND EFFECTS AND- OUR
URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO REDUCING
THE HEAT ISLAND EFFECT BY
PUTTING TREES BACK INTO URBAN
AREAS. PUTTING SHADE IN URBAN
AREAS REDUCING HE HEAT STRESS
ON- COMMUNITIES THAT BY AND
LARGE DON'T HAVE TREES IN THEM
RIGHT NOW AND THAT PROGRAM IS
HIGHLY DIRECTED TOWARD-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE NOT PREVIOUSLY OUT THE
FUNDS OR THE CITIES THAT THEY
ARE WITHIN HAVEN'T EXPENDED THE
FUNDS TO PUT TREES INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. TREES ARE THE
ANSWER- FURTHER WEHAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA FORCED IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM FOREST LEGACY PROGRAM
THOSE ARE LOOKING AT THAT KIND
OF THE FORESTED AREAS AND
HELPING PEOPLE MANAGE THOSE FOR
HEALTH AND- LONGEVITY- AND- AND
IN MANY CASES ARE SEATED.
CALIFORNIA FOR SOME GROUP OF
PROGRAM IS GEARED TOWARD THOSE
COMMUNITIES OR THOSE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO DO THAT
FOREST MANAGEMENT ON THEIR TEN
OR TWENTY OR THIRTY ACRES BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO GET STARTED. SO THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT REALLY HELPS
WITH THAT AND WILL REDUCE THE
EFFECTS AND THE IMPACTS AND THE
INTENSITY OF WILDFIRE ON ACRES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
THAT'S WHERE WE'LL BE WORKING-
IN THIS ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH FOREST MANAGEMENT THE
URBAN WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
AREAS TO REDUCE THE INTENSITY
OF FIRES IT COMES IN THE
COMMUNITIES. HARDENING
STRUCTURES OF DEFENSIBLE SPACE
SO THAT STRUCTURES DON'T BURN
IN WILDFIRES AND OVERALL
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF-
EMISSIONS THAT COME FROM
WILDFIRES. AND INCREASING YES
IT WAS THEN DISCUSSED
INCREASING A LITTLE BIT. THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE. COMPONENT OF.
THE EMISSION. BUT WE DO SMOKE
MANAGEMENT PLANS FOR EVERYONE
OF THOSE WE DIRECT SMOKE AWAY
FROM. FROM THOSE AREAS SO WHAT
YEAH I'M LIKE A WILDFIRE WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PICK
THE WEATHER THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BURN UNDER AND BASS WORK HOW WE
DIRECT WHERE. SMOKE GOES I CAN
GUARANTEE IF WE PRESCRIBE IF WE
DO ALL OF THE PRESCRIBED FIRE
THAT WE WANT TO DO IN THE
FUTURE. NEW YORK CITY WILL
NEVER SEE ANY IMPACT FROM THAT.
GUARANTEED WITH ALL THIS- I
DON'T WANT TO GO TOO LONG
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS- AFTER THE PANEL AND
I HAVE OTHER PANEL MEMBERS-
THAT ARE A PART OF THIS- WE
JUST I JUST WANT YOU KNOW CAL
FIRE IS LOOKING AT ALL SEGMENTS
WERE ALL PROGRAMS INVOLVED AND
WE BELIEVE- THAT- OUR
MITIGATION PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED AND WELL JUST WELL
SUITED TO MEETING THIS MISSION
AND SHARING IT ON FOR DECADES
TO COME. THANK YOU CHAIR AND I
WILL TURN. MY BACK. THANK YOU
CHIEF PORTER- AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
QUESTIONS- APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO FOR.
KEEPING US SAFE OUT THERE AND
FIGHTING THESE FIRES AS OF
RIGHT NOW THIS VERY MOMENT- WE
HAVE TWO MORE PANELISTS WE'RE
GONNA INVITE UP I'M GONNA TURN
THE GAVEL OVER BUT NO WINTER
KEY DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCHER WHO. IS HERE AS WELL
AS MISS LORI LYNN MISSOURI
WHO'S WITH CALLAWAY YES THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND SHE'S THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF PLANNING PREPAREDNESS AND
PREVENTIO- BUT BEFORE THOSE
TWO PANELISTS TAKE. TAKE THE
MIKE- WE WILL TAKE A BRIEF
PAUSE LET US CLEAN THE STAND
AND- I'LL HEAD OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR. SINCERELY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATION TODAY
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP SOON.
OKAY
WE'RE BACK SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND- NORMAN ARE YOU STILL THERE.
I AM I AM HERE AND GIVE ME OR
YES WE CAN GO AHEAD- WE JUST
DID OUR SWITCH AND GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU TO THAT
CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE INVITATIONS TO
JOIN TODAY'S SESSION. AS
MENTIONED I'M DOING PART OF KEY
I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH. AND I ALSO SHARE OUR
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
COUNCIL WHICH IS THE ONLY
PUBLIC BODY IN STATE GOVERNMENT
THAT IS SPECIFICALLY CHARGED TO
FOCUS ON CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE. IN MY COMMENTS
TODAY I'M GONNA DISCUSS YOURS
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE WORK
THROUGH OUR INTEGRATED CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROGRAM AND SPECIFICALLY OUR
WORK TO ENSURE THAT ADAPTATION
EFFORTS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE MOST FORMAL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. I JUST WANTED TO
START MY SECOND NAME ALL THE
IMPORTANT POINTS THAT THE
SPEAKERS HERE TODAY MADE ON
THAT IN A COUPLE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. ACROSS THE
STATE AND- RECOGNIZE THAT
FUNDAMENTALS ARE WORKING- PR ON
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE IS
THE RECOGNITION OF THE
RESILIENCE CALIFORNIA IS ONE
WHERE. NO COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT
BEHIND. SO DO FOR A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT AND- IS THE STATE'S LONG
RANGE AGENCY FOCUSED ON LAND
USE TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING.
TRANSACTION AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE OPR IS WELL
POSITIONED TO INTEGRATE THESE
ISSUES IN THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND LOCAL ADAPTATION
EFFORTS THAT BENEFIT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. THE MOST FORMAL
CALIFORNIANS. AND SENATE BILL
TWO FORTY SIX ESTABLISHED OUR
ADAPTATION PROGRAM ID CARD THE
INTEGRATED CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCY PROGRAM AND ARE
CHARGED FOR DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO ALIGN STATE
AND LOCAL ADAPTATION EFFORTS BY
TAKING A REALLY TRULY
INTEGRATED AND COLLABORATIVE.
AND CROSS SECTORAL APPROACH.
RELATED THE NEED FOR IN TODAY'S
SESSION. AND HEARD THE ENABLING
STATUTE THERE ARE TWO IMPORTANT
CROSS CUTTING PRIORITIES THAT
INFORM ALL THE WORK WE DO. THE
FIRST IS PRIORITIZATION AND
INTEGRATION OF EQUITY INTO THE
SAME EXACT MISSION EFFORTS AND
THE SECOND IS DRIVING ON AN
INTEGRATED CLIMATE ACTION
BRINGS TOGETHER MITIGATION AND
ADAPTATION AS EQUAL COMPONENTS
TO THE STATE'S FRAMEWORK ON
CLIMATE. SO NOW I'M
TRANSITIONING WITH THAT
BACKGROUND AND CONTEXT
TRANSITIONING TO OUR WORKAROUND
IDENTIFYING AND DEFINING
FOLDABLE COMMUNITIES IN AN
ADAPTATION CONTACTS. THROUGH I.
CAR WE'VE BEEN LEADING THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE
OUR WORK ON CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND ADAPTATION IS MEETING THE
NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES MOST
VULNERABLE TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THIS INCLUDES THE
FOUNDATIONAL WORK WE'VE DONE
WITH OUR COUNCIL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN RECOGNIZING THE
DESPERATE AND INEQUITABLE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS ACROSS THE
STATE ONE OF THE FIRST AND
FOUNDATIONAL BODIES OF WORKER
COUNCIL TOOK ON WAS TO DEFINE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN THE
CONTEXT OF CLIMATE ADAPTATION
RESILIENCE SOMETHING THAT HAD
NOT BEEN DONE BEFORE. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M NOT GOING
TO GO TO THE DETAIL IN THE
DEFINITION BUT I'M VERY HAPPY
TO SHARE ADDITIONAL DETAILS OR
FOLLOW UP IN THE FOLLOWING
CONVERSATIONS BUT I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS DEFINITION
FOR WHOLE COMMUNITIES HAS SINCE
BEEN CODIFIED IN SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY. AND IS NOW IN
STATE STATUTE. SO LOOKING TO
OUR WORK AHEAD WELL- WERE TWO.
THE DEFINITE. HAS HELPED LINE
AND DRIVE STATE AND LOCAL WORK
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
SENSE ASK YOUR TO DEVELOP AN
INTEGRATED PLATFORM. TO MAKE
THIS DEFINITION ACTIONABLE FOR
ADAPTATION POLICY AND
INVESTMENT DECISIONS
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE STATE AGENCIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND ADVOCATES
ON THE GROUND. FOR INSTANCE
THIS IS WELL DOCUMENTED IN A
TENSE MAPPING RESILIENCE
REPORT. SO TO ADDRESS THIS NEED
WE'RE JUST KICKING OFF AN
EFFORT TO DEVELOP OUR OWN WHOLE
COMMUNITIES PLATFORM THERE ARE
THREE HIGH LEVEL GOALS AND I'M
JUST GONNA RUN THROUGH QUICKLY
HERE OF THIS EFFORT. THE FIRST
IS DEVELOPING AN OPEN
ACCESSIBLE AND COMMUNITY
CROWDED PLATFORM THE
HOLISTICALLY IDENTIFIES A
COMMUNITY'S MOST VULNERABLE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. MANY OF THE
SPEAKERS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE
CHALLENGE IN THIS EFFORT AND
REALLY HAVE THE- THE SPEAKERS
HERE TODAY AND HAVEN'T I
HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO THE NEED TO A
MUCH MORE INTEGRATED APPROACH.
SO THE SECOND CALL THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO DRIVE ON IS
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS PLATFORM
WILL NOT REPLACE EXISTING
STATUTORILY MANDATED OR SECTOR
SPECIFIC DECISION SUPPORT
TOOLS. INSTEAD PULL THIS
IMPORTANT CROSS SECTOR
INFORMATION TOGETHER HELP
DECISION MAKERS UNDERSTAND THE
UNDERLYING FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE. TO VULNERABILITY IN
THE FACE OF CLIMATE. AND THIRD.
VERY- GOAL IS THE ARGUMENT TO.
YOU FOR LOOKING CLIMATE RISK
DATA TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE NO
LONGER SOLELY RELYING ON
BACKWARD LOOKING HAZARD DATA
THAT DOES NOT GIVE US THE FULL
PICTURE OF WHAT WE'RE FACING.
AND THIS LAST POINT THAT I
MENTIONED IS A GAP IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT TOOL BOX IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE RISKS. IN
CONTEXT OF FUTURE CLIMATE
IMPACTS SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
TO BE DRIVING AROUND IN CLOSING
THAT GAP WITH MY DENNIS LINE.
SO ONE OF THE LAST POINT ANIME
HERE BEFORE I HAND IT BACK IS I
WAS ASKED TO DATE TO
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE A BRIEF
COMPARISON OF HOW THIS WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING THROUGH OUR
PROGRAM TO DEVELOP OUR OWN WILL
TO UNITY'S PLATFORM. COMPARES
TO FEMA'S RECENTLY RELEASED
NATIONAL RESCUE NEXT FALL. WELL
IMMENSELY VALUABLE THERE ARE
TWO IMPORTANT DISTINCTIONS THE
FIRST IS THAT THE PAYMENT TOOL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT GAP THAT
I MENTION IT DOES NOT WITH ONE
EXCEPTION. INCLUDES FORWARD
LOOKING FUTURE CLIMATE
PROJECTION RISK IT IS BASED ON
BACKWARD LOOKING DATA WHICH IS
IMPORTANT. BUT DOES NOT TELL
THE WHOLE PITURE OF WHAT WE
NEED TO BE ADDRESSING. SO OUR
LITTLE COMMUNITIES PLATFORM
AGAIN WILL BRING IN THAT FUTURE
LOOKING INFORMATION FROM THE
STATE'S WEALTH OF INFORMATION
WE HAVE BEEN DOWNSCALED CLIMATE
PROJECTION. DATA THE SECOND
DIFFERENCE IS THAT HE PAYMENT
TOOL TAKES AN INTERESTING
APPROACH ASSIGNING A COMPETENT
SCORE TO EACH CENSUS TRACT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO MAKE
RELATIVE COMPARISONS. IT DOES
NOT PROVIDE US IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THE RIGHT TOOL FOR THE
RIGHT PROBLEM AND THIS
DEFINITELY IS NOT A CRITICISM I
THINK THIS TOOL IS VERY
VALUABLE IN PROVIDING A USEFUL
INITIAL SCREEN. BUT IT DOES NOT
GIVE US IN CALIFORNIA AND
DECISION MAKERS INSIGHT INTO
HOW TO TARGET LOCAL SOLUTIONS
TO LOCAL CONDITIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE TO COMMUNITIES CAN HAVE
THE SAME RANK AND THE SAME
SCORE BUT DRIVEN BY VERY
DIFFERENT RISKS. AND THE
CURRENT- TOOL THIS NOT. IN INTO
UNDER. HOW TO TIE AND THOSE
RISKS THIS IS ALSO A GAP THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO FILL THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR PLATFORM.
SO TO CONCLUDE I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS WORK PRESENTS
CALIFORNIA OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE OUR NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP ON CLIMATE CHANGE
AND RESIDENT BINDINGS JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CLIMATE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. CALLS FOR
TARGETED CLIMATE INVESTMENTS IN
UNDER RESOURCED COMMUNITIES
PRIORITIZING INVESTMENTS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
COMMUNITIES VULNERABLE TO
CLIMATE IMPACTS. WILL
GOVERNMENT STARTS TO MAP OUT
HOW THEY WILL MEET THIS
LAUDABLE GOAL WHICH THEY ISSUED
INITIAL GUIDANCE ON JUST
YESTERDAY. OUR WORK TO DEVELOP
THE FIRST NATIONALLY FIRST IN
THE NATION VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES PLATFORM CAN SERVE
AS A MODEL. SO WITH THAT I WANT
TO CLOSE BY THINKING AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK HERE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE SAME. INVESTMENT
AND EQUITABLE ADAPTATION ACTION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. AND ANY FOLLOW UP
DISCUSSION. WE THANK YOU KNOW
WHEN SO NOW JUST HAVE A LAST.
LAURIE ARE YOU STILL THERE.
RIGHT HERE OKAY LORI WILL END
IT OFF WITH YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAUREN
IS SURE- I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENTION
HELLO YES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
CALLOW YESS EFFORTS IN CLIMATE
DISASTER RISK AND EQUITY. SO A
LACK OF MEANINGFUL AND
CONSISTENT ENGAGEMENT WITH
DIVERSE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL AND STATE
MITIGATION AND EMERGENCY
PLANNING PLANNING. RESULTS IN
PROCESSES PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS
THAT DO NOT MEET THE NEEDS OF
POPULATIONS MOST IMPACTED BY
DISASTERS I THINK ONE OF THE
PANELISTS POINTED THAT OUT
TODAY. WITH THAT IN MIND HELLO
YES IS UNDERTAKEN A NUMBER OF
ACTIONS WITH MORE IN THE
PIPELINE TO ADDRESS THAT
INEQUITY THROUGH VARIOUS
STRATEGIES. AND I'D LIKE TO
SHARE SOME OF THOSE WITH THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. FIRST YEAH
HELLO YES FIRST PUBLISHED THE
CALIFORNIA ADAPTATION PLANNING
GUIDE OR EPG AND TWENTY TWELVE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO. AND WITH
FUNDING FROM FEMA AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
THE TWENTY TWENTY UPDATE
INCLUDES BEST PRACTICES GLEANED
OVER THE ENSUING EIGHT YEARS.
AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS PASSED THROUGH
VARIOUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION
OVER THE YEARS. LAST YEAR OKAY
ARE INTEGRATED A WEB BASED
VERSION OF THE A. P. G. INTO
THE ADAPTATION CLEARING HOUSE.
B. A. P. T. ISN'T AN EVOLVING
FOR PHASE THREE SOURCE DOCUMENT
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ENGAGE IN
ADAPTATION PLANNING. IN ALL THE
PHASES EQUITY IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT BY INCLUDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEANINGFUL
INVOLVEMENT. FROM MEMBERS OR
LEADERS OF FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPATED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND OFTEN UNDER
REPRESENTED IN COMMUNITY
DECISION MAKING PROCESSES. B.
A. P. G. CALLS OUT THE
NECESSITY TO ENGAGE- COMMUNITY
AND FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OTHER NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS SOCIAL JUSTICE
GROUPS NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS
CULTURAL GROUPS AND MORE. THIS
ENGAGEMENT ALSO SUPPORTS
EQUITABLE EMERGENCY RESPONSE BY
BUILDING TRUSTING COMMUNITY
AWARENESS AS WELL AS
STRENGTHENING LOCAL
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
BEFORE DISASTERS OCCUR. FOR
EXAMPLE HELLO YES RECENTLY
JOINED A WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS
SESSION CO HOSTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO DISCUSS
WILDFIRE SEASON EFFORTS WITH-
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. ST CBO
CONTRACTOR SERVING FARM
WORKERS. OFFICE THAT MY GREAT
SERVICE CENTER OPERATORS AND
MEXICAN CONSULATE. THEY THINK
IT IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO COLLABORATE
ACROSS STATE ENTITIES AND WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS THAT SUPPORT
MEETING THE NEEDS OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WHO AGAIN
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN ADDITION TO BEING AN
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY.ANOTHER TOOL THAT
DRIVES ALL STATE PLANNING AND
MITIGATION EFFORTS AT CALLAWAY-
IF THAT THREAT AND HAZARD
IDENTIFICATION AND RISK
ASSESSMENT REPORT BYRON FOR
SHORT. AND THE CORRESPONDING
STAKEHOLDER PREPAREDNESS REVIEW.
SO THE ENTIRE PROCESS HELPS
COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND THE
NORMAL SET OF RISKS THEY FACE
pTHOSE THREATS A COMMUNITY HE
CAN THEN MAKE SMARTER DECISIONS
AS THEY MANAGE APPROPRIATE
PLANNING MITIGATION STRATEGIES
AND DEVELOPING NEEDED
CAPABILITY. USING TARGETS FROM
THE FIRA HUMANITIES IDENTIFY
THEIR CAPABILITIES LOST THE
STAINED AND BUILT AND THIS IS
REPORTED IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PREPAREDNESS REVIEW. THIS
PROCESS PROVIDES THE FOUNDATION
FOR MY TRIP HELLO YES IS
PLANNING GUIDE SUCH AS OUR
EXTREME HEAT CONTINGENCY PLAN
THE POWER DISRUPTION TOOL KIT
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND ONE
OF THE STATE'S MOST IMPORTANT
PLANS TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND CLIMATE DRIVEN DISASTERS
THE STATE HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN. THE TWENTY EIGHTEENS
UPDATED STATE HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN INCLUDES AMONG OTHER
THINGS UPDATED CLIMATE
MITIGATION PROGRESS AND
ADAPTATION STRATEGIES INCLUDING
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES WHICH
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
IDENTIFYING THE INTERSECTION OF
SOCIAL VULNERABILITY
INDICATORS. WITH KNOWN HAZARDS
AND THREATS AND PRIORITIZING
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND FUNDING
THERE. IT ALSO HOLDS OUT BROAD
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AS A
CRITICAL ELEMENT IN THE PROCESS
TO IMPROVE CROSS SECTOR
COORDINATION WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON ENGAGEMENT WITH UNDERSERVED
OR RURAL BOULDER OPAL
POPULATIONS- AND
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS. ADMITS
HE MENTIONED HELLO THIS IS ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COUNCIL FOR I. CARD.
AND PROVIDES AN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE TO THE
PROGRAM. THE GOVERNOR'S LISA'S
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN OR TEXAS
CALIFORNIA FOR SHORT. WHICH WAS
ADMINISTERED THROUGH CALLOW YES
IN CHALFONT TEARS HAS BEEN AN
INVALUABLE TOOL TO ENHANCE
COMMUNITY DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
ACROSS OUR DIVERSE STATE. AND
TO COMBAT HOUSING AND FOOD AND
SECURITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES- INTEGRATED PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LEAST OF
CALIFORNIA HAS DEVELOPED
VARIOUS MEASURES DESIGNED TO
CONNECT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WITH LIFE CHANGING AND
LIFESAVING GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES. FOR EXAMPLE A FARM
WORKER INITIATIVE WAS FIRST OF
ITS KIND EFFORT TO DELIVER
PREPAREDNESS INFORMATION
THROUGH AUDIO RECORDINGS IN A
VARIETY OF COMMONLY SPOKEN
LANGUAGES INCLUDING LANGUAGES
INDIGENOUS TO LATIN AMERICA.
WE'VE CREATED SPECIFIC DISASTER
READY GUIDES FOR FARM WORKERS
AND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND WE'VE
CONDUCTED SOCIAL BRIDGING PHONE
INITIATIVES TO CONNECT OLDER
CALIFORNIANS WITH RESOURCES AND
PREPAREDNESS MATERIALS. WITH
OVER THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES REACHED OVER THE
TWO YEARS OF THIS PROGRAM. THIS
INITIATIVE HAS BECOME A MODEL
FOR THE NATION AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE PUT
ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS INTO CALLOW YESS LEAST
AS CALIFORNIA GRANT PROGRAM FOR
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET YEAR. OTHER CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET ACTIONS THAT WILL
FURTHER EQUITY OBJECTIVES
INCLUDE TWENTY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR A NEW HELLO YES
OFFICE OF EQUITY. AND THIS DOES
INCLUDE THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR LISA'S CALIFORNIA GRANTS
THAT I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED- I
AND SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH A MULTI
AGENCY WILD. WILDFIRE FORECASTS
AND THREAT INTELLIGENCE
INTEGRATION CENTER. AND THE ONE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS FOR PER
CALIFORNIA A PROGRAM TO BUILD
DISASTER RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
THIS LATTER ONE TIME FUNDING
WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES BY
COVERING UP 21100% OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COST SHARE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE FEDERAL.
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM- ALSO TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH TO DISADVANTAGE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS THEY APPLY FOR
FEDERAL GRANTS. THE OFFICE OF
EQUITY WILL FOCUS ON THE NEEDS
OF VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WITH
CONSIDERATION TO RACE
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY AMONG
OTHER FACTORS. WHILE ENSURING
CONSISTENT ENGAGEMENT WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE OFFICE WILL
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN WITH
EQUITY OBJECTIVES THAT WILL
GUIDE NOT ONLY OUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAMS BUT ALSO
ALL OF RESPONSE RECOVERY AND
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES AND
OPERATIONAL DOCTRINE AT THE
STATE LEVEL. BY FOCUSING ON THE
NEEDS OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
THESE INVESTMENTS BY THE STATE
WILL FURTHER STRENGTHEN
CONNECTIONS AND TRUST. AS WELL
AS BUILD RESILIENCY WITH ALL
COMMUNITIES. WITH THAT OUT
BECAUSE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I'LL
STAND BY FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU LORD FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AS WELL JUST ONE CHECK ANY
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. I JUST
HAD A FEW BEFORE YOU GO TOWARDS
THE PUBLIC COMMENT- CHIEF ROSE
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK YOU DO OR- ARE YOU
FOLKS OUT THERE DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME RETURN FIRE
SEASON. ONE QUESTION I ASKED
ONE OF THE FIRST TIME WAS IN
THE BEGINNING REGARDING. THE
CONTROLLED BURNS ARE PRESCRIBED
BURNS HOW HOW YOU WANT TO CALL
THEM. WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT HOW
MANY ACRES A YEAR WE WOULD HAVE
TO BURN IN PART FOR HOW MANY
YEARS TO TRY TO GET A BETTER
HOLD HANDLE ON. ON THE ISSUES
YOU'RE FACING IN THE STATE
REGARDING OUR OUR ARMED. FORCES
LANDS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION BY SHARE- I. THINK
WHAT I'M GONNA POINT BACK TO
IS- THE FOREST CARBON PLAN.
FIRST CARBON PLAN. IDENTIFIES
MILLION ACRES OF TREATMENT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S LANDSCAPES
THAT FEDERAL AND- STATE
RESPONSIBILITY INCLUDING THE
PRIVATE LANDS. 47% OF THE LAND.
IS IN PRIVATE. THE OWNERSHIP.
3% AND BUT I GOT A LITTLE BIT
WRONG 57% IS FEDERAL LANDS 40%
PRIVATE AND 3% IS IN STATE
CONTROL SO OF THAT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES IN EACH OF THOSE
FEDERAL OR NON FEDERAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT DOESN'T
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WHAT YOUR
QUESTION IS HOW MUCH PRESCRIBED
FIRE- SHOULD WE BE PUTTING ON
THE GROUND. WE NEED TO DO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
TREATMENT IN THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE STATE SOME OF THAT WILL
BE- PRESCRIBED FIRE PRESCRIBED
FIRE RIGHT NOW IS GOING TO BE A
SMALL PIECE OF THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF LAND THAT'S NOT
IN A HEALTHY ENOUGH STATE TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY- PRESCRIBED FIRE
TO IT WITHOUT HAVING
CATASTROPHIC- CONEQUENCES SO
WE NEED TO GET WE NEED TO FOR A
WHILE DO A LOT OF FOREST AND
FUELS MANAGEMENT ACTIVITY- AND
THEN GET THOSE LANDS IN THE
MAINTENANCE WITH WILD OR
WITHOUT PRESCRIBED FIRE. AND
GET US BACK TO MORE OF THAT-
TRADITIONAL CULTURAL KNOWLEDGE
AND USE OF FIRE ON THE
LANDSCAPE THAT I WAS MENTIONING
THAT INDIGENOUS PEOPLE DID
BEFORE- SO WE GOT THE-
ECOSYSTEM SO OUT OF BALANCE
FROM WHERE THEY ARE SO RIGHT
NOW IT'S IN THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES MAYBE FIFTY
SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES OVER TIME
THAT NUMBER SHOULD GROW AND
APPROACH AT LEAST PROBABLY IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF HALF OF
THOSE ACRES SOMEWHERE AROUND
TWO HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES. BUT THAT MAY
TAKE DECADES TO GET TO. THANK
YOU TO. OF JUST ANOTHER
QUESTION MAYBE FOR NORM RULE WE
TALK ABOUT THE PROGRAMS ARE
LOOKING TO DEVELOP TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF THE EQUITY ISSUES
AND OTHERS- BUT WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING TO ON OUR DISASTER
MITIGATION PLANS. TO
SUFFICIENTLY MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THAT'S
SOMETHING OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT AS WELL JUST DIDN'T
KNOW IF I CAN ELABORATE A BIT
MORE ON THAT. SO I CAN TAKE THE
FIRST STEP AT THAT- AS THAT
HELLO YES WE DO LOOK AT LOCAL
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS WE ALSO
HAVE THE STATE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS- WE HAVE-
VARIOUS SOCIAL VULNERABILITY
INDICES THAT WE- WE OVERLAY- ON
OUR MAPS. TO IDENTIFY THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY NEED MORE
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND- THOSE.
ARE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES PEOPLE WITH
EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
CHRONIC DISEASES- YOUNG
CHILDREN PERCENTAGES OF OLDER
ADULTS- PERSONAGES OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
OUTDOOR WORKERS IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES- THE LIST IS MUCH
LONGER THAN MY BRAIN CAN
REMEMBER BUT- WE DO LOOK AT ALL
OF THOSE AND ENCOURAGE LOCALS
WHEN THEY'RE PUTTING THEIR
PLANS TOGETHER NOT JUST TO LOOK
AT THE EIGHT JURISDICTION AS A
WHOLE. BUT TO LOOK AT EACH
COMMUNITY WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE ADDRESSED. I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU- ON THAT
AGAIN LAURIE REAL QUICK. YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE LEASE DOES
PROGRAM. CURRICULA FOR IRAN BUT
YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S ANOTHER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION COMING TO-
THAT PROGRAM OR JUST WANT WHAT
WE CAN EXPECT MORE- WITH THE
LEAST OLD PROGRAM. WITH THAT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION MORE COMING.
SO THAT WHEN FIVE MILLION ONE-
IDENTIFIED FOR THE SERVICE
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WAS- WITH
THE- CURRENT OR THE LASTLY
STEPS- ALLOCATIONS OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WERE SPLIT
THIRTY MILLION TO HELP
VOLUNTEERS TWENTY MINUTE
MILLION TO HELLO YES SPORT- AND
THAT TWENTY MILLION WAS USED
FOR. HE CBO GRANTS. SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT- CONTINUATION OF
THOSE GRANTS AND THOSE ARE THE
TRUSTED PARTNERS THAT BANKING
REACH OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND THEY'RE ALLOWED TO SUB
GRANT. SO- EVEN THOUGH WE HAD.
TWENTY FOUR GRANTEES FOR OUR
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ANSWER TWENTY MILLION LAST
TIME. THEY SAID GRANTED TO OVER
THREE HUNDRED LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS SO WE'RE LOOKING
TO CONTINUE THAT SAME- MODEL
GOING FORWARD. IF THERE'S
ANYTHING MORE TO BE ADDED WITH
THE LEAST THOSE PROGRAM THEN
THAT WILL COME BACK IN AND GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF THOSE WOULD BE
ALL THE QUESTION I HAVE FOR
TODAY. AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PRESENTERS FOR PRESENTING
TAKING SOME TIME OUT OF YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULES AS WELL. TO COME
AND SHARE. SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
AND- ALL THE ISSUES FACING
INCOME. SO THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP WHAT
YOU'RE DOING NOT ONLY FOR THE
STATE BUT- FOR THE NATION I
THINK BECAUSE I THINK WE- WE
CAN BECOME A ROLE MODEL FOR
OTHER STATES TO FOLLOW. SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO MOVE ON TO OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND INVITE THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE. THE CALL AND NOW
IF THEY WISH- THE NUMBER ONCE
AGAIN THE CALL IN IS ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE ACCESS
CODE OF EIGHT TWO SIX. EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT. AND NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO. A PUBLIC COMMENT
HERE IN THE GALLERY. SCENE I
BELIEVE THERE IS ONE PERSON
THERE. SO MEMORABLE HEAD YOU
HAVE- TWO MINUTES GO AHEAD AND
STICK TO YOUR NAME IN THE
COMMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THOMAS YATES THE SECOND.
AND I WANT TO APPLAUD EVERYBODY
IN THIS STATE HERE FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
DISASTER THEREFORE YOU ARE IN I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS RATHER
THAN THE CONSEQUENCES SO MUCH
THE CAUSE. AND IT CAUGHT
MULTIPLE CAUSES AND WHAT COULD
BE DONE TO ADDRESS THEN
HOPEFULLY SOME OF YOUR-
POSITIONS OVERLAP INTO THAT
FIELD. SO WE ALL HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT
STOPPING THE CLIMATE
CATASTROPHE WITH ITS RISING
TEMPERATURES CAUSING DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION ON AN UNPRECEDENTED
SCALE. OR CONTINUING TO DRIVE
OUR GAS GUZZLING SUVS AND
PICKUPS. BURNING AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF GASOLINE IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S TOP CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE CLIMATE CATASTROPHE
COMMUTERS HAVE TO REALIZE THAT
THE GAS AND THEY ARE BUYING AND
BURNING IS CAUSING OUR ON GOING
DISASTER. THE MOST IMPORTANT
WAY TO TRANSITION AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS HIS FIRST TEST
START SETTING GREAT GOALS- THIS
PERCENTAGE- THAT PERCENTAGE OF
OUR CLIENT CARBON FREE.
EMISSIONS BY A CERTAIN DATE
WILL NEVER AMOUNT TO ANYTHING
IF WE DON'T START. IT'S UP TO
US NOT THE GOVERNMENT CERTAINLY
NOT CORPORATIONS. IF THOSE
COMMUTERS WHO CAN AND I REALIZE
MANY CAN'T BUT IT FOR THOSE
COMMUTERS WHO CAN SWITCH TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES DID SWITCH TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THEN AND ONLY
THEN WILL THIS DESPERATELY
NEEDED TRANSITION FINALLY START
MOVING FORWARD. THAT'S HOW I DO
THIS DISASTER SO HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THIS MASSIVE LIFTING OF
THE PUBLIC'S AWARENESS.
MOBILIZE CALIFORNIA'S VAST
TALENT IN PUBLIC RELATIONS MORE
ELECTRIC SIGNS ON THE FREEWAYS
MORE PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS TV AND NEWSPAPER
ADS BILLBOARDS OUR REGION EVERY
KIND IMAGINABLE IF ONE APPROACH
ISN'T WORKING TRY ANOTHER AND
YOU WILL ENCOUNTER RESISTANCE
THERE WILL BE MASSIVE
RESISTANCE BUT YOU HAVE TO PUSH
FORWARD THAT THIS HAS GOT TO
HAPPEN OR WILL NEVER GET
ANYWHERE. DURING WORLD WAR TWO
THE NATION'S PUBLIC CUT
CONSUMPTION OF MANY POPULAR
PRODUCTS TO PITCH IN AND HELP
THE WAR EFFORT. HELPING TO MAKE
THEM THE GREATEST GENERATION.
NOW IT'S OUR TURN. I AM
EMPLOYED FULL TIME AS AN
ILLUSTRATOR OF A NATIONALLY
SYNDICATED NEWS ALL RIGHT SIR
CAN YOU WRAP IT UP IN TERMS OF
MY TIME'S UP YEAH CAN YOU WRAP
IT UP REALLY QUICK YEAH YEAH
STILL I'M A PLATE FULL TIME AS
AN ILLUSTRATOR OF A NATIONALLY
SYNDICATED NEWSPAPER STRIP I
UNDERSTAND STORYTELLING PEOPLE
ARE SWAYED BY GOOD STORIES SOME
FICTION SOME NON FICTION. WE
NEED TO PUT NONFICTION
STORYTELLING INTO THE CLIMATE
BUDGET PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
GALLERY SEE NONE HOW ABOUT IN
OUR HEARING ROOM- WITNESS FOR A
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY IN
PUBLIC COMMENT. SEE NON. WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR PHONE LINE-
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
THAT'S CALLED HIM. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. OF
COURSE WE GO TO LINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHASTENED BY ABOUT CALLING FROM
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS THANK YOU. ONE
DURING THE DAY AND ALL THE
PANELISTS. I'M LOOKING TO ADD
TO THE CONVERSATION- IN ONE WAY
WHICH IS. TO COMPARE TO THE
STATE AFRICAN KIND OF
MITIGATION WHAT ARE AT WORK ON
AN ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE-
AS MEMBERS KNOW- CALIFORNIA.
AFTER GETTING THE THIRTY TWO
HAD BENEFITED FROM QUANTITATIVE
EFFECTS ACTUALLY REQUIREMENTS
WOULD USUALLY HAVE DEFINITIONS.
ANY REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE AT
THE GOAL LINE FOR A FOUNDATION.
AND MITIGATING CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA HAD NO SIMILAR GOALS
WITH RESPECT TO CLIMATE
ADAPTATION RESILIENCE. THE
ULTIMATE LEVEL OF A TEMPERATURE
INCREASE IT IN THE COMMENTS ARE
INTACT CALIFORNIA WILL DEPEND
ON HOW WELL THE ENTIRE WORLD
THE MISSION. AND UNFORTUNATELY
GLOBAL EFFORTS TO DATE ARE
FALLING BEHIND THE NECESSARY
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS THE STAY
WITHIN THE PARIS CLIMATE
AGREEMENT COMMITMENT TO KEEP
LOCAL TEMPERATURES. INCREASE AS
WELL YOU COULD TELL. YES THE
CALC MIGHT BE PREPARED IT CAN
BE MUCH GREATER CLIMATE IMPACT
IN TWO TO THREE THIS CENTURY-
BUT CURRENTLY THERE IS NO STATE
POLICY THAT ESTABLISHES A CLEAR
GOAL LINE. HOW WARM THE WORLD
WE MUST PREPARE FOR AND AS A
RESULT LANDING IN THE KITCHEN
MAKING PROPERTY. ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA TAKE VARIED
APPROACHES. IN DETERMINING WHAT
LEVEL OF GLOBAL WARMING IF THE
PATIENT FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
EFFORTS- AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS APPROACH LEAVES. OPEN THE
VERY REAL POT IN THE STATE AND
LOCAL OPINION MAKERS. THE
TICKET MAKING- WILL FALL SHORT
WHAT IS REQUIRED THE NAVAL
CALIFORNIA TO IMPROVE. OR EVEN
MAINTAIN FOR THAT MATTER OF
QUALITY OF LIFE OF THE LOCAL
POPULATION. AND THE STATE OF
THE WHOLE. AND SO WHAT IF THEY
CONTINUE TO PURSUE DEEP
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS- WE HOPE
THE CALIFORNIA WILL CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING A CLIMATE
ADAPTATION BOLD STATE LAW.
REQUIRED STATE AND LOCAL CRIME
APPLICATION PLANNING FIGURE
MAKING BEAN CURD PREPARING
OURSELVES FOR A HIGH IN THE
FUTURE. WHILE PRIORITIZING THE
HELP THEY GIVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. OKAY. THINGS WERE MAJA
OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY I
MEAN WE CAN WORK WITH CLIMATE
RESOLVE WHEN TALKING ABOUT
CLIMATE RISK AND NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT AFFECT
CALIFORNIA. BOTH PLAYERS GROW
THE LEVEL RIGHT FLOODING
EARTHQUAKES AND EVEN TORNADOES
HAVE COME TO A HEAD OF MINE
THESE RISKS. HOWEVER EACH YEAR
EXTREME HEAT KILLED MORE THAN
ALL OTHER CLIMATE RELATED
EVENTS COMBINE. THE COMPUTER
THE FAILING KILLER- PUBLICLY A
FEW WEEKS AGO IT RECEIVED NO
MEDIA COVERAGE ONE OF THE MOST
IMMEDIATE HELP PROTECT THEM
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE. WILL BE
FROM INCREASED TEMPERATURE AND
LONGER PERIODS OF MORE SEVERE
EXTREME HEAT. IN TWO THOUSAND A
MAJOR HEAT WAVE UNTIL YOU KILL
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE-
THANK YOU HAVE BEEN WARNING
THAT MY TWENTY FIFTEEN EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS WOULD TRIPLE THE
AMOUNT OF HEAT RELATED DEATHS.
HOWEVER LOOKING UP TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DEATHS THAT OCCURRED A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO IN THE
NORTHWEST. EXTREME HEAT IS HERE
NOW IT IS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE AND
GROWING IN FREQUENCY AND
FEROCITY. SO WHAT CAN WE DO I'D
LIKE TO MAKE TWO POINTS. FIRST
THERE IS THE NEED FOR EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS AND
RESOURCES. THAT NEED THEM MOST.
THE AREA BEING HELD TWENTY WITH
THE GREATEST RISK OF DISASTER
ALSO THE AREAS THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST THE AFFORDABLE
POPULATION. BY THE. EARLIER
BERKELEY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR I HAVE
VERY LIMITED. AMOUNT OF URBAN
CANOPIES WHICH LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN THIS. NATURE BASED
APPROACHES ARE GREAT WE NEED
MORE CREAM BUT CREEPING IN MANY
MANY YEARS TO GROW INTO A SITE
THAT PROVIDES AMPLE SHADE. WE
NEED MORE IMMEDIATE SOLUTIONS
NOW LIKE- PAVING CREW BUILDING
MATERIALS AND OTHER BACK.
ADVOCATE I REALLY LISTEN. BUT
THERE'S ALSO A NEED LIKE I SAID
I CAN GET FULLY SYNTHETIC
ISOLATING THEM THERE'S BEEN
INACCURATE NOTION THAT SINGLE
SOLUTION COOLING FAN. A BENEFIT
TO THE COMMUNITY WHAT WE KNOW
FROM EXPERIENCE THAT MANY OF
THESE CONTAINERS THE TEMPE
DURING EXTREME HEAT WAVE ONE.
THIRTY SHOW THAT MANY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THE COOLING
CENTERS PROVIDE. HESITANT TO
TRAVEL TO AN UNFAMILIAR PLACE.
THE WONDER IF IT WOULD BE JUST
SITTING IN A ROOM WITH NOTHING
TO DO IF THEY'RE ABLE TO GO
MANY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE THEIR
HOME OR THEIR ANIMALS LOW.
INTEREST GOING YOU DO TONIGHT
CAN YOU RUN. TIMES ALMOST UP
CAN WRAP IT UP. CAN HELP YOU
WITH THE QUESTION. GIVEN THE
HISTORICAL. PARTICIPATION IN
PROVIDING COOLING CENTERS WOULD
IT MAKE MORE SENSE. TO AT
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THE
EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PROGRAM DOES.
INTENSIVE LIFESTYLE EVERYTHING
BETWEEN LOCAL. COMMUNITY GROUPS
THE DESIGN MULTI BENEFIT
RESILIENT CENTER. IN ORDER TO
INSURE THEIR YEARS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. GO TO THE NEXT LINE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWENTY FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE BY SHARING COMMITTEE FOR
THE TOPIC OF CLIMATE DISASTERS
IS OF PARTICULAR INTEREST TO ME
BECAUSE I WAS LIVING IN SONOMA
COUNTY IN THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA WHEN THE TUBBS FIRE
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES IN
THE OCTOBER OF SEVENTEEN
DEVASTATION AS A RESULT OF MY
FAMILY OF SIX IN ME INCLUDING
MY FOUR CHILDREN WERE DISPLACED
WORKFORCE TO MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. THREE OF MY
CHILDREN ACTUALLY GAVE IN
PERSON TESTIMONY A NUMBER OF
MONTHS BACK IN A LEGISLATIVE
HERE IN A LEGISLATIVE HEARING
THERE IN THE CAPITAL ABOUT
USING CEREMONIAL BURN TO
CONTROL WILDFIRES WATCHING MY
CHILDREN GIVE TESTIMONY THAT
DAY WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
ME AS IT BROUGHT UP THE HORRORS
OF THOSE DAYS AND WEEKS. THAT
ARE SANTA ROSA COMMUNITY IN
JORDAN DURING HOUSE LISTENING
TO THIS HEARING TODAY SIMILARLY
UPSETTING FOR ME SH IN JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CAP RADIO AND
NPR CALIFORNIA NEWSROOM
REPORTED NEWSOME OVERSTATED BY
AN ASTOUNDING SIX HUNDRED AND
90% THE NUMBER OF ACRES TREATED
WITH FUEL BREAK AND PRESCRIBED
BURNS IN THE VERY PROJECT HE
SAID NEEDED TO BE PRIORITIZED.
TO PROTECT THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THE
GOVERNOR HAS CLAIMED ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE PRIORITY PROJECTS.
OUT OF THE RULES OF THE JANUARY
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN EXECUTIVE
ORDER RESULTED IN FIRE
PREVENTION WORK ON NINETY
THOUSAND ACRES BUT THE STATE
OWNED DATA SHOW THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF ACRES TREATED THROUGH
FUEL REDUCTION OR PRESCRIBED
BURNS WHAT ELEVEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
THE INVESTIGATION ALSO FOUND
THAT AFTER A SPIKE IN
MITIGATION WORK IN NEWSROOMS
FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE. THE
NUMBER OF TOTAL ACRES TREATED
BY CAL FIRE THE CALL FIND
PRECIPITOUSLY TO BELOW LEVELS
ACHIEVED. DURING THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION. AN ARTICLE FROM
TO AND NINE. I'M REALLY NOT. ET
AND- NINETY EIGHT SITTING OF
THE CALIFORNIA LET'S. TOOK HIM
MONEY FROM PG&E FRANKLY THIS
HEARING SEEMS TO BE YET ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF THIS LEGISLATURE I
HEARING TAKING PLACE AT THE END
OF A DOMINO EFFECT OF
CATASTROPHIC POLICIES THAT HELP
CAUSE GL FOUR NEED TO BE IN THE
MESS THAT IS THEN WITH RESPECT
TO THE FIRE. THE MEDICAL
INSURANCE AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR. OPERATOR HOW MANY
MORE DO WE HAVE TO WAIT. WE
HAVE ONE MORE OKAY- LET'S GO TO
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JAY THAT THING
IN THE FUTURE MEMBERS AND
COMMANDERS- I LOOK WHICH
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- WE WERE GOING
TO START THANKS AGAIN FOR
JOINING YOUR COLOR. ABOUT
COACHELLA VALLEY IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. THE COMPANY
SAYING WHAT HAPPEN SO QUICKLY
FOR THE CONVERSATION GOING
FORWARD ON- RESPONDING TO THE
CRIME EMERGENCY. FIRST HE YOU
MUST YOU MUST BE MITIGATING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN ADDITION TO
ADAPTATION AND UPPING THE
CLIMATE CHANGE ABOUT ME GETTING
CLIMATE CHANGES LIKE TREATING
THE SYMPTOMS- ON. TREATING THE
CAUSE OF THE ELEMENTS F THE
ILLNESS ITSELF. PARTICULARLY
THE STATE MUST PURSUE A REAL
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY THAT
DOES NOT UTILIZE ALL THAT.
WHICH UNDERMINE UNITED
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CLINICAL.
AFTER THE LOCAL CHRISTIAN. WE
AFTER THE CALL FOR COMMENT USE
AND THE TECHNICIAN PROVIDE A
CRIME GOING. THE PURPOSE OF
WORKER FACE COMMUNITIES TO COME
TOGETHER AND MARGIE. AND LASTLY.
ENCOURAGE THE MINISTRATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE VIEW-
PROCEDURALLY RENEWABLE FUEL
COURSES. BACK IN NAGALAND
COMBUSTION. ENGINE NOT EXACTLY
LOCAL POLLUTION. MUCH THANK
VERY MUCH OPERATOR WAS AT A
LOSS ONE. YES THERE IS NO MORE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED IN TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VERSUS. PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OR VISIT
THEIR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS. AN OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND ALSO WANTTO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN CORPORATIONS WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THAT GENDER FOR
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
THIS MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.